to the the main event
right
are we good to go sonia
yes yes chairman right thank you
right welcome everyone to the uh
development committee 26th of november
2020 and welcome to
any uh visitors that are watching in on
the
council's youtube channel we'll do our
best to make sure we explain
each stage and what's happening members
please also remember to
refer clearly to the sections of the
report that you're
talking to um
item one is apologies for absence
they've been received from councillor
western and cancelano
going straight into our substitute
members where we have councillor gooding
substituting for
councillor western and councillor
wilkinson
uh substituting for councillor iano
looking around the screen of non-members
attending
i see councillor whatton councillor iano
councillor rowe councillor steptoe
council
newport cancer mrs mason
cancer the hoy is there anyone whose
name
i have missed
all right councillor canal that's the
canal
thank you
item four is to receive declarations of
interest
please
if you're indicating with the blue hand
plays
let's start with cancer steptoe
yes thank you chairman i had clearly
interest as county councillor for the
uh area of the application
also as ex-leader i had met with bloor
holmes
with the assistant director for planning
and also the
uh referred to them as the residence
group
um who were against the application at
one of
um james statute's mp's surgeries
thank you councillor williams
thank you chairman yeah non-pecuniary
interest being that i am
chairman of rochester parish council and
this proposed development is within
our our parish councilliano
chairman i i've i've got an interest
because i'm the ward council of roach
north and rural
and also i had meetings with the
rochford
supporters group okay thank you
councillor mr shaw again i'm
a wall councilman for roach north aurora
and at the beginning
beginning of this application i also had
uh meetings with the rockford supporters
group
thank you councillor gooding
here when i'm just living just off of
the area and i don't know if that's a
non-pecuniary
interest or not
um it's a it's an interesting clad um
could just ask uh
chris irving if you'd just like to
determine that
that interest please yeah i think just
mentioning it as
an interest for uh transparency is fine
chair thank you
councilman eric thank you chairman
um just erring on the side of caution uh
i am acquainted with the directors of aw
squire limited
and dw squire limited in a professional
capacity in the past
thank you council newport
uh yes chairman i i too have uh had
involvement with rockford supporters
i've been lobbied by bloor homes and
also by friends of the earth
thank you councillor whatton
thank you chairman uh chairman uh a
non-pecuniary interest
as water councillor for the area of the
application
uh also uh i've had as leader
um dealings with law and
rochefort residents rochefort supporters
on this uh
and uh members of our own authority and
essex county council
thank you councillor mr shaw
thank you chairman um an interest as i'm
award counsellor
for the ward where the um school is
actually
in so i think that needs to be
recorded okay thank you and council
butcher
council butcher your hand went up
um can i just come
sonia are you able to confirm what's
happened there
and
um yes besides just off
of the ashington road and i have
okay can't cancel the better your your
showing is muted and not
um can you just take your time because
it's important that we
are clear about this
right can you hear me now yes that's
good thank you
can you hear me now chairman yes i can
yes um i don't know what you've got to
say i'm world counsellor
i also reside off the ashingdon road
and i have had a meeting with the
residence
group in the past okay thank you
uh oh cancer mrs mason you've put your
hand up as well
thank you mr chairman i i haven't got a
pecuniary interest but as
uh the clarification i have met with
members of the rochester supporters
group
but only as um in passing i have never
discussed this application with them
thank you all right i see no more hands
going up to declare interests
so we'll now move on to item five
which is land to the east of washington
road and north of rochford garden way
rochford katie rogers is going to start
as with the presentation please
thank you chairman um before i start my
presentation chairman i'll read out a
further consultation response
received from holt farm junior school
holt junior school appreciates that a
development on this particular site has
already been agreed as part of a
long-term strategy
for the provision of homes in the area
so whilst there is not an
overall objection to the planning for
the number and location of the homes
we need to register our objection to the
current proposal
our objection specifically relates to
the position of the access to the site
being directly opposite the school's
halt farm junior school
and holt farm infant's school and the
lack of consideration of alternative
options
providing safer access to the site
further along ashendon road
the proposed site access specifically
removes a cycle path and narrows the
pavement in front of our site
we believe that this will have an
extremely detrimental impact on the
safety of our pupils and parents
attending the schools
which have overall pupil numbers of 600
plus
the site access also compromises the
access point to the shared car park for
both schools
which is already located very close to a
busy road
with an unmanned pelican crossing giving
us further safety concerns for this
proposal
for both our staff parents and pupils
we believe that there are alternative
alternative sites for access to the
development that have not been explored
simply due to financial implications
which is unacceptable
considering the overall infrastructure
pressures in rochford
particularly along the ascendant road
we request that the planning application
is rejected in its current form to
ensure that the safety of our local
residents
and pupils is not jeopardized to make
relatively small savings to such a huge
huge development project we specifically
request that the meeting ask for
alternative access points to the site to
be reassessed and submitted
chairman i will now begin my
presentation just hold on for
one second members you've got the report
uh that's been circulated but there was
also an addendum
can i just check that the actual
committee members
have all seen that addendum before we
progress
great thank you thank you agreed
yeah i'd like to continue katie please
yeah fine thank you sherman um so now
begin my presentation and i'm going to
share
my screen with you
members this application relates to the
site ed red
on the plan on screen the site is
largely agricultural land extending
beyond the rare gardens of properties on
oxford road to the north
and to the rear garden boundaries of
properties on rochford garden way
persicottis road and the drive to the
south
the application site also borders the
rear gardens of properties fronting
ashington road
to the west there is an existing ditch
shown with my cursor
which runs which bisects the site from
east to west
the site also includes land to provide
pedestrian and vehicle accesses
to the south of the car park um
to a commercial premises um in the area
where my cursor is pointing here
a pedestrian link from the proposed
development um would go through to
washington road
another pedestrian link to washington
road is proposed further south in this
position here
the main vehicular access to the site of
washington road would be achieved by the
demolition
of two existing dwellings at this point
indicated by my cursor here
an emergency vehicle access is proposed
to the south of the main access
at this point here which would also
provide a further pedestrian and cycle
link
a secondary vehicle access at this point
here
is proposed off persecotis road to the
south
i'll take members to a few photographs
of the site
so this first photograph is of part of
the northern boundary of the application
site
the rare garden boundaries of some of
the properties on oxford road
can be seen um and the rear garden
boundaries of properties on ashington
road can also be seen
at the point indicated by my cursor here
just scroll to the next one this second
image is of the north
western corner of the site showing
nearby properties on
oxford road
this third image is to the rear of
sapwoods
on washington road this is the
commercial premises um
and the link through the first
northernmost pedestrian link through to
the ashingdon road
is um would be positioned at
approximately where my cursor is
is there
this fourth image image shows the wider
application site
looking south with the tree-lined ditch
which runs across the site
visible in the distance
this fifth image is taken adjacent the
western boundary
looking eastward um and along
the existing ditch that bisects the site
and finally members um this final image
is of the eastern boundary so it's
looking down the eastern boundary in a
southerly direction
and it shows the rear gardens of some of
the properties on washington road
so i'll take members now to the site
allocation plan
and in particular policy seo the policy
ser 8
site allocation the land shaded purple
and forming the majority of the
application site has been specifically
identified by the council
for residential development and the
principle of the proposed residential
development has therefore been accepted
a small area of the application site in
this eastern part here
lies outside of the site allocation i
outside of that area
showing purple on the screen this is an
area
which remains designated as green belt
in this part of the site strategic open
green space is proposed which would be
used
which would be a use of land appropriate
in the greenbelt
so on screen now is the proposed phasing
plan
this application seeks outline planning
permission for a total of 662 dwellings
and a community building with all
reserve matters of scale
landscaping layout access and appearance
to be determined in relation to phase
one
the phasing plan is shown on screen and
phase one
is all of the area coloured the pink
colour
phase one where essentially full
planning permission is sort includes the
first residential development parcel in
the southwestern area of the site
which is this area indicated by my
cursor here
it also includes the secondary vertical
access of persicotis road to the south
and all of the strategic landscaped
areas including the eastern parkland
the east-west ditch and an area of green
space
um centrally positioned adjacent the
northern boundary
in relation to phases two and three
outline planning permission is sought
including only the matters of layout and
access
for determination at this stage phase
two
which is colored green includes the only
non-residential element of the proposed
scheme
which is land for the community use and
that is
indicated by my cursor on screen here to
the south west
of the site so i'll take members now to
the
phase one layout plan
so within phase one a mix of detached
semi-detached
terraced and flattened housing is
proposed the entrance avenue
which is indicated by my cursor here
would lead off the main vehicular access
and will be tree lined with dwellings
fronting the street and leading to an
amenity green space
with dwellings fronting around and onto
this
street trees would also be would also
feature to one of the roads leading
northwards and indicated by my cursor on
screen
all of the proposed dwellings will be
provided with policy compliant immunity
space
and on-site parking provision a variety
of parking solutions is proposed
including
driveway parking to the side so these
this indicating here of my cursor this
is an area
of detached dwellings with parking
spaces um to the side of each one and a
garage beyond that to some
in addition some of the flatted blocks
so for example in this area here
have communal parking courts in some
areas parking will be provided to the
front of dwellings
indicated in one area by my cursor here
and that would be broken up with tree
planting
the majority of dwellings which would be
cited on plots with a direct boundary to
existing nearby dwellings so here
alongside properties
existing on washington road and here
again to the south and then along
um the southern boundary would be cited
such that the real
elevation of proposed dwellings would
face the site boundary
in most cases an appropriate separation
would be achieved to ensure impacts
relating to overlooking
and overshadowing would not cause
unreasonable harm to the amenity of
existing residents
if i take you to sorry
okay
so on screen now is the phase two and
three layout plan
so the layout of phases two and three
again proposes a mix of dwelling types
detached dwellings are proposed which in
the main would front onto the proposed
green spaces
so along this corridor here all the
dwellings would front on
as would the dwellings along the um
fronting along the east and parkland
space
there will be two vehicle crossing
crossings of the ditch
so one indicated here by my cursor and
the
other just further west here and in
addition
there will be four pedestrian crossing
points indicated by the yellow
arrows on this on the plan on screen so
that's here
and then here here and the furthest west
one would be there
this would allow for good connectivity
for pedestrians within the development
allotments are proposed within the
eastern open space to the eastern end of
oxford road
indicated by my cursor on screen a
children's play space
here and bmx track just adjacent are
proposed
in the southern part of the eastern
partland
a pedestrian and cycle link would run
the length of the eastern open
space indicated by my cursor
to allow link through for pedestrians to
oxford road
and the drive occupants of the site as
well as existing residents would benefit
from good pedestrian
links to allow access on foot to a
number of nearby facilities and
amenities
including local primary schools
take you to the street
street scenes plan so the scale and
appearance of dwellings proposed within
phase one is also for determination in
this application
the plan on screen shows a selection of
street scenes proposed within phase one
the street scene at the top of the
screen
indicated by my cursor
shows a section of the eastern avenue
of the entrance avenue which would lead
off the proposed vehicular access to the
site of washington road
the dwellings proposed are a mix of 2
and 2.5 story
with traditional form incorporating
pitched roofs
and positioning of windows and doors
which would exhibit a strong degree of
symmetry
a mix of render and brickwork facing
materials are proposed
i just scrolled down
so the street scene um
second from the bottom so this one
indicated here by my cursor
includes the proposed larger three-story
flatted block
with use of contrasting facing materials
to break up the elevations
the scheme would deliver the council's
policy requirement for 35
of the dwellings to be affordable in
terms of appearance
the market and affordable properties
proposed within phase one would be
similar
with the same palette of facing
materials to be used
the street scene second from the top
this one here
is a series of proposed market
properties whilst the bottom street seen
on the screen is a series of largely
affordable properties
save for this one i'm at the end
indicated by my cursor here
and in scale and appearance these
properties would be similar
on-screen now is one of the street scene
visuals that's been provided
and contained within the submitted
design code this is an image looking
towards the entrance avenue
indicated by my cursor there which would
link to ashendon road
from within the larger amenity green
space proposed within phase one
houses would front this green space and
be of 2.5 story height
to create a different character and
sense of place to this part of the site
overall in terms of scale layout access
appearance and landscaping it is
considered that the proposed scheme
would achieve good design
in keeping with the character of the
locality as well as these detailed
matters
other key matters are for consideration
in the determination of this application
and that's set out in detail in the
committee report
i'm going to take you back to this
phase two and three layout plan to just
go
through some of those considerations
so this plan shows the layout of the
whole site
including strategic green spaces
in the south east and corner of the site
members will note
indicated by my cursor that two
attenuation ponds are proposed
surface water from the development
parcels would flow
into these ponds via a pipe network be
stored
and then discharged off-site at a
controlled rate
in addition a flood alleviation scheme
is proposed as part of this application
to address an existing surface water
flood risk to parts of the site
the key features of the flood
alleviation scheme include a proposed
attenuation basin
adjacent to the central part of the
northern boundary
indicated by my cursor here a ditch
alongside this along the western
boundary of this
which would outfall to the existing
ditch which bisects the site and runs
east west
these features would ensure that none of
the proposed dwellings would be subject
to unacceptable risk of surface water
flooding
the proposed flood alleviation scheme
would also reduce surface water flood
risk to some existing nearby dwellings
particularly those downstream so
indicated by my cursor here
go back to the phase one layout plan
and i'm just going to zoom into this
plan
okay
so the phase one layout plan includes
the proposed new vehicular access onto
ascendant road indicated by my cursor on
screen
the formation of this access would
involve changes within the highway
adjacent including the formation of a
ghost right-hand turn
and widening of the northbound
carriageway
which would reduce the width of a
section of the footwear to the west
this is adjacent to the halt farm infant
and junior schools
these works would also necessitate the
removal of an oak tree within the
footway
which is indicated on this plan as this
dashed
circular line here indicated by my
cursor on screen
the loss of the oak tree would be
compensated for in part at least by a
financial contribution to enable
significant tree planting
within the district and the proposed
additional
highway tree planting within ashland
road which would take place here just
north
of the school site so indicated by my
cursor
in this location here
take you to a photograph
so the photograph now on screen is taken
on ashington road looking south
at approximately the point at which the
new access to the site is proposed
approximately where my cursor is is here
the pedestrian crossing which is shown
on screen would remain but be
upgraded as required essex county
council high resolution authority raised
no objection to the proposed vehicular
access to the site on the grounds of
safety
the submitted transport assessment in
addendum to this has robustly assessed
the impact of traffic from the proposed
development on the local highway network
the committee report details the
mitigation proposed which would include
improvements to some junctions in the
locality
the report is also clear that some
residual impact on the local highway
network would remain
but essex county council high risk
authority do not consider that this
impact would be severe
in addition to junction improvements
that would be required of the developer
significant financial contributions
towards public transport improvement
and cycleway improvement would also be
provided
to take you back to the phased
two and three layout plan financial and
other contributions will be provided to
mitigate impact from the increased
population
including relating to education
provision where contributions will be
paid in relation to early years in child
care
primary and secondary education the land
within the site satisfied for the
community building which is indicated by
my cursor on screen
would initially be offered to the nhs
for delivery of a new primary health
care facility on site
in addition to a significant financial
contribution towards this new
infrastructure provision
the site has been allocated by rochefort
district council for residential
development
and the delivery of housing here would
support the requirement that the council
maintain a five-year housing land supply
the development would also deliver a
significant number of affordable homes
and would create an attractive
well-designed place for new residents in
a sustainable location
within walking distance for range of
existing facilities
i'll just take you to an aerial image
the last
image so this is an aerial image of the
site
and i'm just going to point out where
the site is so
it's this field here indicated by my
cursor on screen
the site is within walking distance of a
range of local facilities and amenities
including a number of schools so we've
got the whole farm infant and junior
school
opposite the site on washington road
as well as waterman primary school in
this location
indicated by my cursor king edmonds
secondary school
is just north of oxford road
there are shops at golden cross parade
and only slightly further afield is
rochford train station
which will be readily accessible from
the site by cycle
as set out in the committee report it is
considered that the adverse impacts of
the proposed development
would not significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits of the proposed
scheme
importantly there is no objection to the
proposed development from the highways
authority
and the development is considered to
accord with relevant national planning
policy
and the adopted development plan which
specifically identifies this site for
residential development
the recommendation therefore chairman is
one of approval subject to the
recommended planning conditions
and a section 106 legal agreement to the
heads of terms
as detailed in the report and addendum a
slight adjustment to the wording of the
contamination condition are set out in
the addendum is also recommended
to ensure that the further ground
testing as identified in the submitted
contamination report is carried out
a mitigation agreed also carried out
prior to the commencement of development
it's
on the site in addition um
the additional condition relating to
reptile mitigation on the addendum is
not required as this is already covered
by condition at number 16. thank you
thank you
if you could um just possibly
cut the share then okay
we have three um speakers
on this one first one i'd like to call
is mrs sally faulkner
deputy clark rochford parish council
um five minutes we'll let you know when
you've got a minute left
thank you mr chair water of parish
council acknowledges that this
application is broadly in line with the
requirements of the local plan
there are several areas which council
would like
development committee to consider whilst
the numbers and units and density are
within guidelines
it is noted that both the unit numbers
and density is higher than the local
plan
unit numbers have been increased by over
60 percent
and although density is only slightly
increased it is much higher than the
existing properties which are 25 units
per hectare
the council is very concerned about the
effect of the development on the
ashington road traffic which is
acknowledged to be over capacity it's
difficult to see
how the suggestion for traffic flow to
be staggered could be achieved within a
residential
and education environment
persicotis road is very narrow to be
used as a secondary vehicular access
and it already has parking passing
issues
sorry which may increase following
this use we would also ask that you
consider
whether 10 schools parking places is
sufficient
or if usage could be monitored once
the new facility is open
the parish council also requests to be
consulted regarding the access from
braids lane via dog its clothes onto a
tight
corner and any impact this may have
or the development may have on the
docket's wildlife area
i.e noise dust mud and whether the
current surfaces are suitable for the
vehicle types
the council acknowledges the replacement
of trees and shrubs
however are concerned at the length of
time it will require
for happy paths to be re-established
paris council request involvement in
discussion
as to the need for and management of
the allotments play space open space
community buildings as we can provide
information
on local requirements for allotment and
give an overview on local facilities
we would ask that a recommendation
sorry we would ask that a condition be
placed on the development
working hours to reserve disturbance to
existing residents
i.e monday to friday 7 a.m to 4 p.m
saturday and sunday 8 a.m to 3 p.m
our parish council has recently met with
blah holmes and had a discussion about
some of these issues
and we are looking forward to future
discussions as other phases come on
board
thank you mr chairman for allowing the
parish council to have representatives
speak at your meeting
thank you very much the next speaker is
mr robert
yverne planning director blah holmes
the applicant when you're ready up to
five minutes
your officers have presented a really
thorough and robust report to recommend
that this
allocated development site should be
approved
national planning policy demands that
sustainable development should be
plan lead and i am pleased to commend
this scheme to you
at the culmination of a comprehensive
process
led by your local plan this site is the
last development of the 2014 local plan
it delivers the requirements of site
policy ser-8
therefore the principle of development
has been firmly established
this project is due to be delivered when
economic recovery
new homes accompanying infrastructure
and employment opportunities
are significant national priorities our
planning applications to mission
followed years of extensive consultation
with the community
stakeholders and council officers the
scheme presented to you today
has the full support of statutory
consultees
the application is an outline with the
first 233 homes
fully designed in detail planning and
design officers
have facilitated a scheme of enduring
design quality
which respects local character at an
appropriate density
while meeting standards for parking
garden sizes and sustainability
the development will be climate change
resilient and built to accord with a
detailed design code
to maintain a site-wide consistent
quality standard
the site will also deliver sustainable
urban drainage together with a new flood
attenuation feature to fix existing
flood issues historically
experienced by adjacent residents with a
good range of homes for families and for
smaller households
the proposal responds well to housing
needs
all of the homes are designed to be
compliant with nationally described
space standards
the policy compliant 35 affordable homes
as supported by housing officers
will meet a range of local needs and
help key workers get on the housing
ladder
moreover these affordable homes are
built of the same materials
as the market homes along with same
design characteristics
and high quality specifications they too
will be built by hook law homes
which is reviewed as the highest rated
national house builder
on the trust pilot review platform and
has a formal nhbc five-star
accreditation
for customer satisfaction thus it's a
socially inclusive scheme
and these are all really great quality
homes irrespective of kenya
there has been much scrutiny of the
access proposals to absolutely reassure
you
these have been designed modeled
assessed and safely audited to
to make sure that they prioritize the
safety of all road users
the transport assessment process has
been rigorous and exhaustive
the scheme is pump primed by an
extensive package of highway
improvements
before the delivery of the first home
along with a new
700 000 pound fund for improved bus
services
and 250 000 pounds for cycling
infrastructure
the highway improvement measures are
supported by the home authority
and achieve the safest possible access
regime
for the site throughout the planning
process
it has become clear that the development
of necessary highway improvements
will lead to the unavoidable loss of the
significant street tree
this aspect of the works is considered
in three ways
new street trees are proposed further
additional tree planting is planned
to allow for future skyline trees in the
development
and a direct compensation payment is
agreed this application promises over
8.3
million pounds of infrastructure
improvements for school places
libraries preschool provision and other
facilities we also deliver community
building land
for the nhs along with a substantial nhs
funding package which local nhs managers
are very keen to put to good use
these benefits are in addition to a
school drop-off zone
new recreation land ecological habitat
and allotments
our focus on creating a great place will
continue throughout the construction
phase
which will be managed by a detailed
construction management environment plan
in summary the scheme delivers necessary
and well-planned development it
mitigates its impacts
it delivers infrastructure it pays its
way
and at absolutely no cost to the public
purse these are not vague wishes
but they are resolute and legally
binding promises
the promised infrastructure is presented
at the front end of the office's report
and is also the last line of this
lengthy plan led
process as you move into the next stages
of this project
i thank you for putting your faith in us
and respectfully ask that you endorse
the recommendation
and approve this planning application
thank you very much
thank you very much um and our
final speaker on this is melanie english
rochford supporters if you just unmute
your microphone
and then when you're ready you've got
five minutes
thank you thank you mr chairman
there is no doubt to any of us that the
ashland road is the blight of every
person's life who has to use it
we concur with councillor one that the
survey should never have been allocated
into the current local plan
it was short-sighted unrealistic and an
error of poor judgment made by your
predecessors
they handed down to you a loaded gun but
you should not be accountable for
mistakes made by others impaired
judgment
the rodford supporters believe this road
is an
inadequacy combined with the fact that
no amount of money will provide solution
should be enough for you to bravely deny
this application
citing the entrance to this proposed
development obviously an infant junior
school is irresponsible
it will be an accident waiting to happen
children's safety should never
ever be compromised just to comply with
unrealistic housing delivery targets to
finance the developer everybody knows
this road is the bane of residence life
it takes to it is an obstruction and
will create gridlock
such as a recent set of temporary
traffic lights placed on top of the
school crossing
a thoughtless action which resulted in
motorists sitting in gridlock for up to
an hour
this is a narrow class c road unsuitable
for the amount of traffic
it is expected to serve recently we have
had two near fatalities and that is two
too many
yet here you are constrained by policy
and expected to fairly consider
this application by law who intend to
exploit this land to its absolute
maximum
ecc have again stated the road can cope
yet in their highways report they
clearly state that by 2029 the
retro-road junction will have major
problems
consider your own experiences and ecc's
prediction
why would anyone recommend this
application
it is bloor's intention to reverse
recent changes made to the retro-road
junction
which were made because of safety issues
and in return
to its former design to ease traffic
flow which will once again put people's
lives at risk
some schools have declared that they are
fully capacity
gp surgeries are required to take more
patients but this does not translate
into a prompt appointment etc data is
compiled using artificial computer
generated algorithms
which do not represent real life or real
time we only have to look at the recent
gcse
and a-level fiasco which used algorithms
that did not work
a virtual world has the ability to make
anything appear that everything
is a perfect fit but the reality does
not represent
boots on the ground tars tires on tarmac
children in school places or available
gp appointments
for that you need human eyes ears and
brains yes this is what is required of
you to consider
when judging this application computer
generated pictures statistics from law
and algorithms from ecc
this is the wrong development in the
wrong place in the event of this
shocking and inappropriate over
development going ahead
in any form then we must reluctantly
touch on the subject
of design and layout law has portrayed
utopia
but the actuality will be very different
from what is proposed
take the 2.5 story home these homes have
two flights of stairs and three floors
and are three story and far too tall
they will dominate and overlook the main
bungalows
which surround the size of the perimeter
and have been there for many years
taller homes smaller footprint this is
not about design it's about
quantity more homes can be worked into
the same space it's an illusion intended
to be deceptive
affordable homes which is in fact social
housing
this is a slick market employee and very
likely a lot of this type of housing
will be bought up and out
by town authorities on the open market
rather than a hundred percent going to
local people
consideration to go now must be given to
the siting of such homes
rather than place them around the
boundary council councillors we must put
our faith and trust in your hands that
you will do the right thing for your
town and residents
this development is not the right thing
we hope your decision will take into
consideration the far-reaching
catastrophic impact
that it will have on this area at the
residence of years to come
a parting comment from floor when we
voiced the concern in relation to the
mounted bike track
and likelihood of it being hijacked by
groups of youth anthony calvert said
we can put another 100 homes on there if
you prefer we rest our case this
arrogant and greedy throwaway comment
from anthony calvin
we do not mind which party runs his
council
so as long as they do the town and the
residents the best interest of the
forefront
right now the residents are our near
breaking point
because of this proposed development
thank you
right could i ask those
non-members of the committee that
wish to say anything to please indicate
in the first instance please
thank you um i'll start with uh it's a
lot of hands uh
count councillor whatton please
thank you chairman uh i speak as one of
the ward councillors for the area in
which this development is planned
in opposition to the proposals i speak
on behalf of nearly all
if not all of the 1545
respondents the two rochford district
council consultations
yes to repeat 1545.
i speak in support of the numerous
representations set out in section 4 of
the report
opposing this development including from
rochford parish council canudan parish
council
hawkwell parish council ashingdon parish
council
stanbridge parish council hagglesham
parish council
and the right honourable mark francois
mp
chairman we cannot all be wrong there
are many
areas and aspects of concern whilst
these are covered in the report before
you this evening
in the very short time i have available
i will highlight
and focus on just a few i am concerned
about over development
when i became aware of this site being
allocated and adopted for residential
development back in 2014
long before i was a counsellor frankly i
was surprised
there is no natural highway access to
the site even it is within an already
densely populated area of the district
and proximity to already highly
congested roads
it feels the wrong area for yet more
housing the allocation is for 500
properties or thereabouts
we are looking tonight at an application
for 662
over 30 percent more than the original
allocation
i believe that this is excessive over
development of the site
and very much at odds with densities
elsewhere in the district
looking at the style and layouts the
overall appearance will be a significant
variance
with the surrounding street scene and
character of nearby residential areas
i note that there does not appear to be
any provision for five bedroom
properties
a point that was drawn to the
applicant's attention at a very early
stage
in particular i also draw the
committee's attention to point 4.89
of the report page 5.85 where there is a
comment by essex county council urban
design
about their concerns in respect of
shapes of some of the gardens
and the need to avoid a car dominated
environment
the style and type of development will
inevitably appeal to families
there is no real explanation on how
these requirements will be addressed
to accommodate school places or medical
facilities in the area
which are already operating to capacity
turning now to highways matters everyone
who lives and works in the area needs to
use the ashland road regularly
knows what a significant artery it is on
a daily basis at potentially all times
of the day
it can become heavily congested and the
consequent delays it causes users in
order to reach their destinations
percy cottage road is a wholly
unsuitable alternative access to the
development
the rockford garden way estate is well
designed and attractive development
but with relatively narrow roads
combined with on-street parking
navigating via somerset avenue on the
drive back to washington road will be
difficult
with the likelihood that on average each
property will have two cars
it is obvious to anyone the usage will
contribute significantly
to an already heavily congested road
network
acknowledged by isik county council
highways experts
even before any further development
takes place to be over capacity
and to have already reached a severe
level by adding hundreds of additional
road movements per day
i note the proposal talks about several
changes to the road layouts along
washington road
none of these actually address capacity
it is interesting to note that the
ashingdon road retro junction will be
changed back to a layout
similar to that which existed previously
and which was changed on county highways
recommendations a couple of years ago
on grounds of safety that defies logic
to me
a requirement is to model and create a
junction along ashington road which
forms the main access to the development
in the immediate vicinity of holt farm
school covered at 3.111
page 5.49 in essence this requires the
removal of an attractive and very old
tree subject to a preservation order
which is objected to by the rdc
agriculturalist
c point 4.35 it also reduces the pay
volt width immediately outside of the
school
to minimum standard as pointed out by
ethics county council growth and
development team
in points 4.54 and 4.55 of the report
this element of the proposal alone is
quite disturbing as it will create a
complex road layout
directly opposite halt farm primary
school
this will become the main access and
egress point for pedestrian traffic
and will lead to injuries and potential
fatalities with young and very young
members of the community it is
considered that the intensification of
pedestrian conflict
which is further exacerbated at school
times cannot be overcome by mitigation
measures
if approved this application would
therefore have a serious
detrimental effect on pedestrian safety
and lead to an unacceptable level of
risk
in conclusion in my opinion the proposed
development
is wholly inappropriate in scale and
location
as well as existing infrastructure
chairman
i accept this is a difficult decision
for the development committee tonight
but i should like to thank you and
members for listening to my concerns
thank you thank you uh councillor no
next please
thank you chair chairman
members rochford district uh officers
and residents
as the independent council for roach's
northern rural
i'm here this evening to present
the residents of my ward in reference to
the planning application
i would like to thank the officer of
rochford district house
for her presentation of this application
which the development committee will
debate later this evening
and hopefully adhere to their
understanding of the application
and its impact on the community of
rochford
after digesting mountains of material
delivered to my premises
i'm of the opinion the reports are
flawed
with inconsistent supporting documents
and a letter i understand by the
developer
on the local community infrastructure
such as
road networks schools surgeries
wildlife policy rate compliance
local plan allocation of housing
and access points to name a few
regarding the road network the
developing tends to provide
monitoring injections into the road
network by upgrading
locations near the question site
a couple of roundabouts local traffic
measures to name a few
the developer has not considered the
impact on the wider road
network namely smaller roads serving
all locations which cannot be widened
accident which is the potential meaning
that the traffic can only travel
in one direction west that is
by the a127 all via hockley and rayleigh
which are both already struggling with
capacity
the ta in the application report
acknowledges
that the road network is at capacity
and that the roundabout at hall road in
ashland road by the railway station
cannot be upgraded and will not cope
with the increase
in traffic the introduction of more
buses
into the already congested network
will also cause mayhem to the local
community
and is a sweetener to the development
committee
committee regarding access points
the proposed second access point by
persicotis road
is not fit for purpose to sustain the
additional traffic from the proposed
site
and since it's a small road it has
minimal scope to be expanded
the developer proposed an access point
opposite hulk farm school which leads in
onto
ashton road is an accident waiting to
happen
no consideration has has been prepared
to accommodate the safety of the
children
at hulk farm saint trees kidney admins
and the general community the developer
fails to understand that
10 parking bays will not be sufficient
as a normal school run there are in
excess of 10 cars delivering children to
the schools in the morning
and afternoon which again will create a
gridlock
on ashland road regarding the outside
scope of sear eight
the initial land allocation was for 500
homes to be contained within seer eight
this application is for 662 ohms
and the and the leisure parts of the
develop plus
allotments and etcetera will fall
outside the cr8
onto green belt land this is only
happening
now to uplift the number of units built
regarding the local plan sure 8 was
allocated in the local plan
and adopted in 2014 some six years ago
to my knowledge there has been any
review of this plan since 2014
which is appalling for rochford
community the allocation in 2014
has 500 homes not 662 homes
regarding the c8 compliance the policy
83 states that an uplift of 5
can be applied if certain conditions are
fulfilled
the council cannot demonstrate a
five-year land supply for housing
there is insufficient land locally for
development
the council can demonstrate a 4.9 year
land supply which equates to four years
10 months 24 days
which is therefore contentious which
since the council cannot demonstrate any
lack
of land locally for development
therefore cea
is non-compliant in conclusion
points that i've raised this evening
shows that the developer has a lack of
understanding of
rochford area and the community on the
aspects
of road networks access points the local
plan
cra compliant compliance
now okay
so i i i
implore that the development committee
to uh reject
the application thank you um
councillor next please
thank you chairman whether we like it or
not
all planet authorities are responsible
for providing sites for homes
as we all know that this site is an
allocated site
however for me 660 homes is over
development
not to mention my concerns in relation
to the school
i work with young children and for those
of us lucky to have children
we all know they can be very impulsive
at times
their main access is leaving us wide
open for serious accidents and possibly
fatalities
on an already busy road
i have concerns that essex the essex
county council
think that there's no safety issues and
as usual never object to anything
thank you thank you
councillor steptoe next please
thank you chairman just before i start
could i could you ask the officer
uh if they could put the picture up of
the pelican crossing that that she
showed
sure if you want to start talking as
this goes out please
thank you i'll start to start my
presentation
although the principle of planning on
this particular site has been
established
it was back in 2014 uh that this was uh
part of the uh strategy and of course
the only assessments would have been
prior to that in 2012 2013 and nothing
has changed well nothing has been
uh updated since then i also accept the
fact that the
highways department with the uh proposed
access to the site have to look at it as
presented
and of course they will comment on that
but that does not necessarily mean that
it's the right place to have
access access to the site
in principle was meant to be up towards
the sapwoods
area there's a much larger area there
where the site could have an access
and a proper junction be put into place
well away from the schools
to pick on a place to put a junction
such as this
outside the school i don't think you
could find a worst place
i would like to point out looking at the
photograph that you have there
uh there you can see the tree on the
right hand side uh which will be removed
and then pavement
why on earth have if they're going to
have this development
why was not the white road widening to
the left of the picture
where there is an access road i do not
understand why they had to do that
there is no reason to know it here of no
reason why
also as well it would be quite a simple
operation to put a proper drop off and
pick up point
along where that service road is is
currently
and in top of the 10 places
we have to remember that the road
network that we're talking about here
was laid out in medieval times
it is not a new no road network
the only changes to the road network in
rochford
since then was the hall road which was
put in as a toll road in the 17
1800s and bradley way which was to
bypass the town centre
which was around about the 60s or 70s
there has been no change
in the road network in rochford since
medieval times
the access to percy cottage road has
already been mentioned several times
it is totally inappropriate where it is
looks on paper it looks like a good idea
but it in reality it is not if they are
going to have to have the site
then that needs something needs to be
done about that particular access
i simply don't believe that this access
to this road
is the site is in the right place
with the contributions that they are
putting towards other junction
improvements
there's been nothing said about the
junction of hall road
south street sorry west street and the
ashenton road
it's almost impossible to improve that
junction without removing a school
moving a river and moving a railway
bridge
so that is going to remain the same and
we will have difficulty coping with the
extra traffic
there was nothing put forward for the
junction of west street and bradley way
and nothing put forward for the junction
of
bradley way and south street also
junctions that are badly over subscribed
there was some funding put forward for
the amber lynn junction
which recently had a bit of an upgrade
for money from
the whole road estate but again there's
not much more you can do with that
but it's an interesting point there is
lots there's going to be a lot of gas
work
uh done there where they're going to
have to remove the existing roundabout
so maybe there's an opportunity there to
actually improve that particular
junction
just about a minute to go cancer stepped
out thank you chairman
i would urge the committee to reject
this application
of the points that i've raised the
safety of our children is paramount
and by closing down that footpath we are
just increasing the danger
or if they can't come to agreement to
refuse
deferment and suggestion to the
applicant that they go away and think
about this particular
situation with regards to over
development
we have to remember that in the east of
the rockford district
we have had to accommodate with the
planning applications that are before us
in other areas and are already existing
buildings happening
something in the region of two thousand
houses
this is starting to get to be a problem
because there has been
no improvement to the road network and
the infrastructure of the area
if you could draw to a close please i
cannot believe
so i urge the committee to either reject
this application
or at least defer it so you can go away
and think about it again
thank you very much um next council ahoy
please
thank you chairman sorry my video is
playing up there um yeah thank you i
will be
um as brief as possible um i would
not try not to repeat what everyone has
already said
i i do have problems with this
application as you probably expect
um i see many of the problems with this
application that we've seen
with all of the other large applications
within the district um
and particularly with regards to the
inspector removing the five percent cap
on buildings and the number of the
quantity of buildings
um i think one of the main problems
at present if we look at the detail of
the application
is around the new access point um
this and i'm bumbling around looking for
my
the point i need i found it um i just
want to draw your attention to um
paragraph 4.54
which straddles pages 5.74 or 5.75
um if you're looking online
as i am it's 75 of 111 pages
this is um the response from the essex
county council
growth and development team i'm going to
read you the full paragraph because i
think it's quite important
it relates to the um
ashington road junction opposite
hulk farm schools the new junction
they're going to put in
a number of comments and recommendations
are made main concern relates to the
proposed
location of the main access egress into
the site
outside holt farm schools from the south
along the
south through the development of a
dedicated right turn lane
on washington road we appreciate that
the applicant has undertaken
pre-application engagement with the ecc
as the highway authority for roger
district however we are not convinced
that the proposals external to the
development site
but within the application boundary
align effectively with the national
planning
policy framework
[Music]
2019 requirement to deliver healthy and
safe environments
through higher quality public spaces
which encourage the activity and
continual use of public areas
now this is clearly relating to the
narrowing of the path outside hulk farm
schools
from six meters to three meters to
removing the current cycle path and
making it a shed shared cycle path which
are troublesome i know we have one in
holbridge
and the the problems that that is going
to cause the the reduction in size
i think councillors should very much
bear this in mind
when they're looking at this this is a a
consultant responding to report
and this is echoing
and backing up comments made by
councillors already about this junction
and um i think believed by melanie
english as well
and i think this is one of the most
important paragraphs you'll read
reading this report which you should
bear in mind when you vote on this
application
um first of that i would just like a
question answered if i made from the
officers and i would like this i know
we don't always get questions answered
as visiting members uh you
well i think it's very relevant that we
actually know what's happened to the um
youth space it's quite clear in the um
in the um local plan
that there there is supposed to be youth
facilities
which can be indoor and outdoor but at
the all i can read in the report
is a is about a community space being
for the nhs
potentially i have seen nothing for
youth facilities at all
um beyond the possibility they may be
there i would
i would like councillors also to bear
that in mind that
if they are voting for this today where
are the youth facilities
thank you thank you um
councillor newport please
thank you chairman sorry um i was under
the impression that we would have um
questions answered as i've previously
submitted some questions
um to officers
um cannot so i don't know if they're
gonna get answered tonight
so i'll try and bundle them into um
i haven't pre-prepared a speech at all
so firstly um
well done to rochefort supporters for a
very passionate speech um
and how i would start my um
scrutiny of this is basically there's a
lot of concerns
around the highways i've i had
very very little time to read the report
as i was given the hard copy
for just 24 hours which wasn't offered
to other members of our group
so they too have only had 24 hours
um one of the matters that we
previously raised as lib dems is our
financial matters of material planning
consideration
if tonight we are told that is true
it should be questioned we have an
opportunity here
we've heard from many councillors about
concerns with the highway
i have it on good authority that you can
question that you can ask for an
independent report
it is not outside of your control to ask
for that
i've read the traffic assessment
and i'll draw your attention to the
addendum um page 6
2.17 and i quote
that the software is not well suited to
model the impact
of additional traffic on approaches
already operating close
or above theoretical capacity
you should question whether that makes
these traffic assessments
sound we've heard from
law saying that this application has
been supported by officers
but it's clearly not supported by
residents and certainly not by
councillors
we've said about they've said about the
tree
planting in the district we have no tree
planting strategy
in the district it's something the lib
dems have called for
and we still haven't got it it's a car
centric
application when you look
at the problems that this application
will bring it's staring you in the face
the all the children at that school
this is their future and here we are
looking at building another load of
houses
which is a car centric design
so what is what is the housing density
and we must question as to whether this
can be increased
in phase two and three in other
developments in the district
we've seen where the developers come
back and increase the density
you must question this and ask how many
houses that this site
can actually accommodate this is a trick
that developers have used
in other areas in the district and do
you trust what they are saying now
in my in my opinion this scheme is poor
in design
and it is not something that i would put
my name to
i think we should be considering our
futures
we should be considering that of our
children's futures
these houses are not the type of houses
that we need
in our district in its current format
i would ask the committee tonight
to consider either refusal
or deferring this application pending
an independent report into the traffic
and that is what i implore you
to consider thank you thank you
all right counselor mrs mason please
thank you mr chairman
i have today received a letter from
blair holmes
stating that they hope i will support
their application
they also state that they have engaged
positively
with elected members and i would like to
place on record
that i am not one of those members
this is a large and complex planning
application
and it is therefore important that we do
not lose sight of the main principles
regarding potential development
where roxford sacrifices greenbelt we
should have high quality homes as
required by our residents
which are not necessarily the same as
the homes that a developer may wish to
supply
when their main objective is usually
profit
scr8 was placed in the now out of date
cos
strategy with an anticipated capacity of
just
over 500 dwellings not
662. this increase in my view
results in an over development of the
site
the access adversely affects the local
school
which should be of concern to everyone
this and the road issues have been
comprehensively
demonstrated by the previous speakers
a local infrastructure is already
inadequate
and the report provided states that the
whole road
ashington road junction cannot be
improved
and i suspect that traffic studies
underestimate
the true difficulties that are
experienced on a daily basis
by our long-suffering residents
of concern is rdc policy of requiring
developers
to deliver a wide choice of high quality
homes
based on both current and future needs
which is not in my opinion delivered by
the housing mix
proposed where are the bungalows for
elderly residents
wear them one and two bed flats for
purchase by our local community
noticeable in their absence the only
flats proposed
are those for so-called affordable
housing which is housing provided to a
housing association
of the developers choice not affordable
or accessible
to our local residents that may want to
purchase one as a starter home
another policy that is apparently
ignored is the one of tenure blind
affordable
also known as social housing
the documents state that the affordable
homes are tenure blind
they are not it is not tenure blind if
affordable housing is allocated flats
and none are placed on the open market
it is not tenure blind if affordable
houses have parking spaces
as opposed to garages provided for
marketing properties
it is not tenure blind if affordable
houses are in terraces
but the marketed ones are not
neither are the affordable homes pepper
potted
as our policy requires but clustered
which can
lead to future social problems we should
not be treating our residents in need of
social housing as second-class citizens
nor should we be denying choice to
potential market purchases
two house styles on the plans provided
show flat room
dormers again against policy another
concern is the regrettable increasingly
common practice
of planners putting in a three-story
building
and describing them as 2.5 it's
misleading
and apart from recent years it's not
characteristic to the area
one raring factor that seems to be
glossed over
and i this refers to the um
section 106 proposals is that the
proposal
includes a management company to
maintain and oversee
public open spaces and the surface water
drainage system at residents
costs on top of their purchase price or
rent
and council tax this is a hidden burden
and one that should not be passed on to
residents but by
covered by council tax and reuters
district council should obtain a
realistic amount
from a developer under the section 106
so that new residents are not treated
differently
to those on older estates about a minute
ago mrs mason
thank you unfortunately what many
purchasers don't realize
these amounts are not capped as
s-r-e-s-e-r-a sorry there
is regrettably in our local plan we have
to consider it
as a potential building site you know i
would ask members to consider the
concerns expressed
over traffic the proposed access
housing allocations and design the
problem of passing future uncontrolled
management costs
onto residents all this should show this
application should
be at best refused but if it is felt
that all the concerns that will be
raised can be resolved
at least deferred personally in its
present form
i would prefer refusal thank you mr
chairman
thank you and the final one of our
visiting members
councillor canal
thank you chair members ashington road
was not designed for the volume of
traffic it currently receives
and often severely struggles during peak
periods
speaking of local residents has made it
very clear that they are worried about
the impact of an additional 600 plus
vehicles
will have on traffic congestion and air
quality
as a councillor for down hall and roar
this is a concern i'm used to discussing
and for that reason i often start my
reviews of development committee reports
at the infrastructure section
i was happy to read this application's
report contains an acknowledgement of
current and future challenges on
washington road
as well as measures to mitigate against
them such as the section 278 agreement
for improvements
two key roundabouts and thirsty cuttings
road
it was however very concerning to read
the transport assessment of addendum
item 3.98 page five four
five point four seven of the report you
are considering
this item focuses on the remodel of the
junction
the road junction capacity analysis
requested by essex highways
and concludes that several arms at the
ashington road hall road
west street junction are predicted to
operate
above practical and or thought theory
ethical capacity
and it has identified that the traffic
from the development would add to this
increasing cueing and delay it also
concludes that no
junction improvements are possible here
it is disappointing and perplexing
therefore that essex county council
highways have no objections to this
proposal
i object to this proposal i believe this
application to be over development
at 162 units more than the 2014
allocation plan
cites and it will clearly cause further
stress on an already failing
local road network
members this report is lengthy and
detailed as i suspect this evening's
proceedings to be
so i'll be briefed with my final couple
of thoughts
plans for cycle pass in the proposal are
keenly noted and i hope this trend
continues and moves us towards a fully
connected
cycling network in rockford
condition 18 is also welcome as our
river and sea boundaries make certain
parts of the district successful
susceptible to flooding including parts
of rochester town
as shown by previous events on oxford
road spencer road and born close
development of additional housing should
not pose further challenge
or risk to existing residents homes
families
or health thank you chair
thank you very much that
concludes the input from our visiting
members
so now we go on to the development
committee
so again please raise your your hand
if you're wanting to take part um
there's a lot of speakers tonight i'm
conscious
that we have a proper discussion but
please do ensure that you
raise all your points uh when you get
your opportunity
and uh i i will ask you members not to
go beyond
uh five minutes in whatever you're
you're saying
so i will start please with counselor
gooding thank you chairman
um item 5 5.3 which
refers to the off-site highway
the two lane entries and changes made to
the road markings
in particular with ashingdon road and
rectory road
this junction was deemed necessary by
essex county council highways
to alter the the junction only a couple
of years ago and to
improve safety measures by taking out
the two lanes from rectory road
to to doing this reversing the same
action
it seems to me that it's not the safety
of the pedestrians that is being
considered here but more the decision to
suit the development
like i'd like to stop you for a second
council against my opinion
can i just stop it for one minute um
we've lost councillor wilkinson
and this says um
if he's lost and we continue he uh
he'll disbar himself from the meeting
but i can't hold up the meeting
i'll just go giving him a moment
okay you want to continue councillor
gooding
yes so likewise with the ashington road
junction with the west street and hall
road
which has already been mentioned i
acknowledge that but no development
improvements are planned i see the area
is already a bottleneck becoming further
gridlocked
as the increase of dwellings become
inhabited
and residents with two cars per
household can potentially increase the
current use by another 1200 vehicles
at least
on page three point 549
one one refers to the right hand turn
and the junction leading off ashendon
road
um opposite holt farm school
i know there's some changes which is not
only the carriageway but the footway
will be my concern is for the parents
and the children
which are required by law to attend the
six
schools whereby ashingdon road is their
main
route the six schools have one thousand
six hundred and forty students and
approximately a thousand
parents traveling along the ashingdon
road
these figures do not include the 13
feeder
nurseries which will add to the
2640
already accessing this road the proposal
to narrow the footpath outside hulk farm
school
where i'm advised up to a thousand
parents and children
would need to access this footpath which
is proposed to be reduced
to the minimum width is in my opinion a
poor option and potentially an
accident waiting to happen having
an adverse impact on the existing
infrastructure
in addition to this i refer to the item
5
3.77 where the allocated parking
facilities for the school
with 500 children attending halt farm
school alone there
clearly is insufficient parking
all these items need to be considered as
far as i'm concerned before i could
support this
so i would recommend a deferment or a
refusal
thank you counselor
mrs shaw please thank you chairman
one point before i speak on this our
application i'm disappointed some
members have made this a politic it's
political it's not
we should have the interests of our
residents at heart
i'm a member an associate member of the
rtpi
and we get various documents coming in
regarding planning
the construction and i have difficulty
understanding um
why we have a the construction of a
junction
serving around 600 plus houses which
will be directly opposite the hulk farm
schools
young pedestrians will be using this
road and i feel there is a potential for
accidents
as there will be an increase of
pedestrians at school times
i know this has been covered by other
members but as a world
councillor i feel that i have to say
this
if approved this would have a serious of
effect on pedestrian safety
children don't look at times they just
run
and they can run across this fatality is
going to happen
also if you refer to chapter 12 of the
mppf
national planning policy framework
achieving well-designed places
these designs fail to have any
relationship with existing developments
with within the area
council like michael hoy actually uh
came on to the
the next one page 5.2 item six
on the second of the 11th members and
officers
we had a zoo meeting with bloor
we were told the uh over spill of
parents
using the school for parking would be in
a community center
which i can't see that happening but now
the community centre's disappeared and
we've now got an nhs dwelling
going to be put up there well the
overspill
car park now cannot be used because if
it's nhs
they'll have patience there so
the times the school so we have now lost
the 10
parking spaces along that road
i was we as most of us do we use this
road
on a daily basis and you can have at
least
20 to 30 cars on the slip road
wait dropping off their children these
are young children
parents will not just drop the children
and
let the children go across this crossing
it's still completely
dangerous i cannot support this i will
vote for refusal thank you thank you
councillor mr shaw thank you chairman
a number of the points i was going to
raise have been covered by
um other councillors but i would uh
item 5.45 on
page 5.74 i would extend that
points through to page 5.75
and items 4.61 it covers a lot of items
that haven't been brought up and haven't
been discussed
item 3.52 page four
five point four five is ashington road
dailies road and roach avenue junction
this identifies that the road will be
widened
um both ways in washington road coming
to the roundabout
to make this a two-lane entry
and also there will be modifications to
dalys road to make that a two-lane entry
nothing is mentioned of any improvements
or modifications to roach avenue
there's been a number of accidents there
because of
a blind spot on that corner also
there is no mention of what's going to
happen
to the two bus stops along washington
road
which just prior to the roundabout
which will obviously be affected if the
road is widened
item 3.109 page 5.49
is the secondary access development
of person into perticottis it states
that there would be a link
across from attitude this would link up
across to ashton road
the route would be convalescent so that
such an
extended that the rat run would not
likely result
if you create a rat run you get a rat
run
item 3.244 paid 7474
of the local plan states arrangements of
roads on site
should be that it would not facilitate
the creation of a through route between
ashland road
the drive and persicotis what you're
being given now is it's going to even
though it's convoluting there's going to
be a through route
percycottis road is a very narrow road
it is stated that is going to be widened
but it may be widened
but it goes down to somerset avenue
which is a road narrow road itself
it is also blocked with
[Music]
excess street parking which makes
navigation a lot
harder if you get to the t junction
you turn right you end up back on
ashington road
just prior to the junction with daley's
road
you turn left you go down to the drive
turn right and right you come to a
roundabout
again you turn right you end up
at ashington road you turn left up north
street
you then send all the traffic through
the town
there is not the infrastructure will not
take
all this traffic it also also been
mentioned
about the 10 drop-off points they're not
drop-off points
if anybody knows the school now parents
arrive at
the road there already an hour to an
hour and a half
before the school closes so they can
pick up their children
this is going to happen already
also mr powell thank you i would also
like to um draw
attention to 4.119 on page 5.94
essex please they state the mppf
promotes pre-planning consultation there
has been no planning consultation with
the police
thank you chairman thank you
um next it's it's going to be councillor
wilkinson
councillor wilkinson you did uh
disappear for a period of time
which could cause a problem with your
participation
however there is uh an amount of
repetition
so um we're we'll allow this time
but please don't disappear i i apologize
i actually thought i'd turn my video off
chairman sorry i need to go to the
toilet to apologize i'm so sorry
um chairman members thank you um
i have to say the passion which i've
heard people speaking tonight has been
uh amazing um we've heard from the three
ward councillors
the area who've represented their
residents um fantastically
we've had a a very interesting and very
informative history lesson from cancer
steptoe um and that's really interesting
to hear
about the the the history of the road
network uh i sympathize with absolutely
everything that's been said tonight
and i'm not going to repeat most of it
at all in actual fact and
i'll say where my concerns with this are
um let's start with the road network
and something that counts that yuanu
alluded to um
i think a lot of people forget that
rocha district geographically sits on a
peninsula
and you can't go north you can't go east
you can go south to south end if you
want to go shopping but predominantly
everybody goes west
so that means that everybody comes past
ocala
holbridge uh rayleigh there's only two
main access routes
um and we've got three large
developments already
between this proposed development and
the outside world and that's
rorith polbridge and hall road
and we're now talking about adding
another 600 odd houses to that
and i think it's just there's no way
that not just the ashland road and the
network around there
our network full stop can't cope with
this it can't cope with any more at all
um and i think that you know with the
the the the i'm not going to go over the
the the the other things that other
people have said because they've
all spoken at the junctions already um
the
ashington road is no way that it's not
it's going to cope with what's been
proposed
secondly chairman the access points um
this is not acceptable
um for the reasons we've already spoken
about percy percy because his road is
too small
and it cannot happen outside of farm
school on the on the basis of safety
amongst other things that can't happen
what concerns me is that this is outside
of the scope of scr8
and why it's been the uplift um
from 500 to 662. our policy seo rate
says an uplift of five cons
can be applied in certain circumstances
if it can demonstrate a five-year land
supply
cannot be um or cannot demonstrate a
five-year land supply
we've got 4.9 years so i think we're
splitting hairs there
um and uh and
if the council cannot demonstrate any
lack of land
uh locally which of course it can so
this is not compliant with scr eight in
any way shape or form
the density of the dwellings is supposed
to be the local plan allows for 30
dwellings per hectare
paragraph 3.22 of the report says that
this proposal is 33.1
uh dwellings per hectare the other thing
i'd like to draw members attention to
chairman
is the actual local plan itself which
has been alluded to by several members
and quite rightly so
this is a piece of land that's
designated within the 2014
local plan which would have taken a
number of years before that
we've seen what's happening with our
current new local and how long that's
taken so this would have taken equal at
the time
um and yet we've heard from from cancer
steps again who's our previous leader
has confirmed that of course there's
been an upgrade
um to this uh this local plan there's
been no review
of this local plan which is already over
six years old
section 10a of the town and country
planning act requires local authorities
to review the local plans a minimum of
every five years
so i'm assuming that's not been done i
don't know that it's been done and
therefore
this local plan is no longer compliant
though we cannot or nobody can rely on
the fact that scra is allocated within
that local plan i would suggest
um chairman i've heard everybody
speaking tonight
and i'm not gonna support this and in
actual fact chairman i wish to move a
motion of
refusal um on the grounds of over
development
of the application site it's not scra
compliance the local plan
is not uh valid anymore um and it's so
it's
um and the local highway network is not
is not sufficient
for the the uh this amount of traffic
which sections of policy that needs to
be recorded in chairman for casey i'm
not sure
um but those were the grounds for me
moving a motion for refusal
uh thank you councillor williamson um
before i look at that in detail a number
of other members have
indicated they wish to speak if you
don't mind
uh we will hear those out before
councillor wilson
can hear me now yes thank you yeah thank
you chairman
um others have said that the the roads
are at capacity in the area and i know
that from personal experience
and others are rightly focused on the
road safety of
children um but i've got a particular
concern
which is to do with the pollution along
this road
um the risks to children particularly
pronounced and that's because they
they tend to be exposed to higher
concentrations of pollution
pollutants than adults do and that's
because they're immature
they're developing their immune systems
um and also that they've got a
relatively high inhalation rate
and also children tend to spend a lot
more time outside
and tend to be at the right or wrong
height as it happens
for exhaust emissions so um washington
road
is actually quite unusual in terms of
its relatively narrow width
the number of schools that are along it
and also the stop-start movements of
vehicles
and this therefore poses a greater risk
um
there's no physical room to expand
ashington road
and which regularly gets blocked so and
it
not necessarily blocked for long periods
of time but what this leads to is
um lots of stops start driving and this
type of driving style
increases the number of pollutants that
are being released
what's been noticed is as time goes on
the nitrogen dioxide emissions are going
down but emissions from
particulates from car tires and
from brake systems
is going up and on ashlington road this
is
this road itself is a prime candidate
for that style of driving unfortunately
um picking up something that that
council newport said and it's to do with
the modelling i've been involved in
modeling myself before
and um models tend to try to simplify
the real world they're not actually
infallible they're not there to say
exactly what's going on
they simplify and within the the
transport
assessment addendum as paragraph 2.17
and within the addendum to the air
quality assessment
paragraphs 2.19 and 2.20
they both acknowledge that the models
are not infallible
and i i would go along with council
newport's view which is that we
perhaps need a second independent
assessment of this
the um the reports tend to err on the
sides of of
optimism they tend to under
underestimate the risk to children
and some of this is to do with the
methodology of
obtaining um the measurements of the
pollutants
the um the systems that have been used
within the report are the the diffusion
tubes
and the diffusion chips give an average
and what this means is that it doesn't
take into account
the peak buildup of pollutants along
washington road
so as parents are walking their children
to school if there are lots of vehicles
stop starting along there
the amount of pollution goes up but the
way that this has been measured and it
is an industry standard measure but
there are other ways of doing it
this will only pick up the annual
average
and the thing about this is that
children actually
don't go to school for the whole year
they tend to go
because of the average they tend to go
during the most polluting periods
if you notice by and large traffic is
more
um dense during term time so therefore
there is more pollutant and this is
hidden away if you use an annual average
just a minute um so really to sum up i
i would welcome a second report
in using perhaps a different methodology
um
to validate what the risk to children's
health is
from pollutants along the road thank you
chairman thank you
chairman a point of order emotion was
put on the table
um and it hasn't been seconded and i'd
like to do that
yeah the counselor sure
um to a good number of members had
indicated to talk
prior prior to this i'm doing them
courtesy of
letting them have their say before we
focus down the argument
so that we can clearly go all aspects of
the the debate tonight
we've got a good audience i think that's
only fair um
councillor stanley is next please
thank you chairman um
first of all i'm reading through some of
the literature from
uh blur homes uh as you know my
speciality is in the drainage and i'm
looking at the drainage impact
assessment report
this is from the anglian water services
and
richard lyon in his report he says
this report has been undertaken in
response to an inquiry
from evans rivers and coastal
to determine the impact of flows from
the site of washington road
rochford on the performance of the
existing
foul sewage network it should it should
be read
in conjunction with the pre-planning
report dated the 31st of may
9th 2017 which indicated that a direct
connection to the public sewer
system is likely to have a detrimental
effect on the existing sewage
network it was conducted concluded that
further hydraulic assessment is required
to enable angular water to provide the
solution
for draining of the foul workflows from
the proposed development
the analysis has been performed on the
foul system
only not the surface water there has
been no consideration of the surface
water flows
as this is not within the scope of the
study
that's this particular study the study
concludes
the additional flow fail flows from the
development side
comprising of 500 homes
were assessed not 662
connecting to the manhole
at the location of the drive at the
southeast boundary of the development
area
the study concludes that the development
will cause
detrimental
to to the capacity of the sewer system
and will result in
increased pollution risk downstream of
the proposed connection point
it has already been by uh
the suds team that there are at times
overflow of sewage from that area
um plus the fact that i call
to your note that the premises
to which we are talking about have flat
roofs
to the front of the buildings i thought
that the
rdc had a policy of having pitch roofs
not flat roofs to the roofs um
on that on on our polit on our policies
or of building
furthermore according to
uh paperwork from blur homes
is the ditch running through the center
of the
of the premises where you've got
culverts
now we know for a fact that culverts
don't work
in as much as they always get blocked up
and through
leaves or branches that are coming off
the trees and we're planting quite a lot
of trees
by the sounds of it so i'm not too sure
how that is it an open culvert
or is it got a grill to it um how who's
going to
survey it who's going to maintain it uh
and how that will be used um
the other thing that comes to mind on
the plan
are several parking spaces to the rear
of
the west side of properties in ascendant
road
these has there been any modeling
to show what effect that the car parking
arrangements will have to the properties
at the west side and would look
to see uh modeling from
um the air quality uh
survey if there has if there has been
one if there hasn't then i would like
their one to be
just a minute also cancer stanley to go
okay thank you
uh furthermore i would like to propose
a motion that we have an independent
traffic survey and air quality on the
site
for this particular reason
as to the welfare of the residents and
those
joining the property in their gardens
thank you
thank you counselor eve snacks please
thank you chairman uh there's been a
vast amount of paperwork that's been
generated with this and it's
it's quite overwhelming to some of us to
actually be able to go through all of it
um a lot of the points that have been
picked up with i
totally agree with uh today one of the
things i want to concentrate on
is the uh traffic assessment that was
given to us i
have read through it and uh there are a
number of things that
concern me um when we go
to the addendum if i just pick out some
of the things that are actually written
and quote from there uh
on page six section 2.17
this has already been mentioned uh
the software is not suited to model the
impact of additional traffic
on approaches already operating close to
or above theoretical capacity
turning to the page 8
the section 2.25
i quote to continue to operate the
ashington road north approach is
expected to continue to operate just
over theoretical capacity
um so the figures that are above that do
indicate that we are above uh the 85
which is recognized widely as being
capacity of
the roads the um
page nine washington road south is
expected to operate above practical
but below theoretical capacity with the
2020
basin development flows in the peak amr
and just
over theoretical capacity in the peak
hour
age 11 section 2.38
shows that the junction is predicted to
operate over theoretical capacity with
2029 base flows and so the arcadia model
is unstable with queuing and delay
rising
exponentially again the figures above
that suit do
tend to indicate over 85
capacity page 12 the addition of
development traffic will add to delay
and cueing at the junction however
not to the extent predicted by the model
since this is unstable
as such the results should be treated
with caution the problem that i have
with theater
there are many more examples of this as
i go as you go through this report
sometimes we are uh indicated that we
need to
uh look at the modeling and um
agree with the modeling and sometimes we
are not
so as members trying to make decisions
based on these reports that are put
forward so when they come to us
they are so conflicting within the
report i'm not sure
how much weight we can actually give to
this now we are actually told that we
can't actually
question the um the authority
because these are our statutory bodies
that are actually
producing or agreeing to these reports
but when they make such
obvious um gaffes on these kind of
reports it's very difficult not to
question it
so i would very much support a um the
call for uh
in a totally independent traffic report
one of the things that i find rather
strange about this and i'm glad to see
that there's someone
representing essex highways here i'd
like to
understand from them how much of an
improvement they expect
by putting in the dual lane
approaches to the roundabouts that we're
talking about on the improvements
reason being why i'm asking that is
because
we have an example down the road
which gives us
plenty of evidence that this kind of
approach
to mitigating for the traffic
uh expected increase just a minute ago
thank you uh patently does not work uh
if we go to the
roundabout uh by the railway bridge in
retro
richie road uh sorry uh hull road uh
there are two lane approaches there but
it
even the representative from bloor homes
who
um presented to members a couple of
weeks ago
he admitted that that does not work
because what actually happens you've got
the two lanes there and they are used
but the the two lanes are not used side
by side
uh traffic follows behind and on on some
of the approaches to that particular
road
they are very short and not usable so
you've actually got a
situation there where they are not
useful the other thing is um
that is the those the suggestions for
the improvements attention
completely mirror that i cannot see how
it is
that that is going to improve the
traffic flow there the other thing is
just uh um
we have on our if you could just sum up
now please
very very quick one then amberlynn we're
told that they're going to be spending
100
000 on the upgrades there i think it is
only out of respect
that we are told what that hundred
thousand is going to be on
there is nothing in the report that
indicates that thank you thank you
thank you um councillor fd
uh is next please thank you chairman
um all right what's your development
plan
doesn't specify entrances um
so my personal opinion i don't think
they could have chose a worst entrance
to that site at all
the site looks nice with the houses it
it seems
quite quite a nice sight i've got no
real objection to the house a site being
there i think it's
over development i don't see why
we're pushing the park bit of the area
onto green belt when they could
put it inside the site and reduce the
housing slightly so that's what they did
um it's got a couple questions is there
many electric charging points
on the site because bringing electric
cars now that needs to be looked at
um i've got a cycle way joining cherry
orchard
and watchful town centre
um i'd like to know how this is going to
work
because looking at try to look up what
cycle plans are we've got in the future
and some of this cycle plan
goes on to washington mode and i think
cycles cars buses
children on ashington road is i think a
little bit too much i'd love to see how
essex are going to put this together
this is 250 000 pound of 106 money
which can't be spent on anything else
um i i can't support this
and the way is with the access and the
road
i'd ask for deferment
so that's that's me done thank you very
quickly five minutes
thank you um councillor hookway please
thank you chairman um
i don't want to extend the meeting by
equine uh the points raised by
uh many if not most of the other
councillors in relation to
the access road
issues about um traffic and
basically i agree with
what has been stated and i think that an
independent
traffic uh survey is is something that
we we require and should be part of
any motion um whether whether that is
a um rejection of the application
or deferment um i have got a couple of
um
uh matters which uh i'd like to ask
katie
um to uh if you ask through the chair
please counselor if uh
if yes if the chairman could uh
pass these on to uh to our planning
officer katie so that she can
um um respond to them um
one is um there doesn't seem to be a
uh contract con construction management
plan
in relation to this application and i
wonder
uh has is there any particular reason
why
um that has not been put forward
um uh is there any details about a
construction management plan um uh at
all
um and uh the
uh the other matter is in relation to
wildlife which we shouldn't uh uh
overlook
uh the impact on our local wildlife um
i understand from uh some uh something
that i read that uh
there is uh issues with badges
and as a protected species we need to be
uh very careful of how we deal with
uh with badgers i wonder if katie could
uh
indicate as to uh where um badger sets
if there are any identified on-site or
where there's badger activity
and what is being proposed
in relation to uh to them
and how any development may mitigate
against the impact on
on the badges um also
within the design of the development
is there any um
any part of the design which um is going
to
uh help or assist local wildlife
within uh the site i mean
generally speaking um gardens are
fenced off um and these become
areas where wildlife might not be able
to
move freely through through the site if
there isn't any
um mitigation for things like uh
endangered
wildlife like hedgehogs and other other
um small creatures as well
as i say in respect of the the issues
raised
about traffic and stuff like that we
shouldn't forget
about the impact on our local wildlife
thank you thank you
councillor williams please
uh thank you chairman firstly i'd like
to
thank officers for an excellent report
and
a very full report thank you could we
would it be possible chairman to share
the screen again with the
the picture that we had previously of
the crossing please
yeah well if you'd like to start talking
while yeah we're getting that up for you
okay well that's part of it um oh it's
there now
right this
this is coming from from the north going
towards the south
um on the right hand side where that
where the the um
the fencing is there is a cycle lane
there
that that footpath is to be narrowed
what is going to happen to that cycle
path
it comes down from on the ashland road
from the north and it crosses on those
lights
and then continues on the left-hand side
going towards rochford i'd like to know
what's going to happen
is that cycle path going to remain
um i don't have a problem with this
development
it is an allocated site and i accept
that we will have to have
in the future some kind of development
there but
in my opinion essex highways have
accepted that this is
acceptable they're wrong i'm sorry
they're wrong
i've sat in this position where we're
looking now for many hours of my life
that i'd rather not have
um what we seem to have forgotten is
that in the two-mile section of the
ashton road it's from washington to
rochford
there are five schools six if you count
the infant school at whole farm
we're going to create another road that
these these students will will have to
cross
we were told at the original
consultation with the developers
that the new road leading to the state
would be controlled by
some kind of pedestrian controlled
crossing that's not the case
um i'm not happy with this at all
i know that we have had a proposal for
refusal
i don't know if i can but i would like
to propose that we defer this
just at this moment counselor uh
williams uh i was letting everyone have
a go and then out of courtesy
um i did i did say i would go back to
councillor wilkinson
okay thank you if i could just
just ask you to hold four minutes and
make your points for the moment okay
that's fine thank you very much um
i think councillor gooding said
something like sixteen hundred
children use this road going to
different schools sixteen hundred
children go to
quez alone let alone the other schools
so i suspect it's more like
possibly of two to three thousand
students using this road
i've had grave concerns and i i really
could not accept this but could as i
said i would much rather have a deferral
for further consultation
thank you thank you if we could just cut
the screen share please
um and counselor butcher please
you've just need to unmute just takes a
few seconds to react
thank you chairman yes i'm having
trouble with my mute and i'm muting
tonight i'm sorry
um i know that we've had a lot of
discussion tonight about this
um this plan and i don't really want to
repeat what
others have said but it seems very clear
to me
that this is very much over development
um it is quite overbearing in this area
i don't like the style and layout and
the design
there's no relationship with existing
houses
the highway access is poor
over capacity on ashington road and
percy cottage road
and most importantly the safety of the
children
using that road so i just wanted to get
my point in
thank you thank you now
every member that's indicated has had
one chan one opportunity to speak so
i'll now
ask katie to um
do a little sum up of where we are at
this point before as
as stated we go back to councillor
wilkinson
thank you
thank you chairman um so there are a
couple i noted down a few questions
specific questions
so what i propose to do is take those
first if that's okay just to
to provide an answer to them um and then
chair if you want to let me know whether
you'd like me to comment on the reasons
for refusal that have been
put forward not yet not yet fine so
i'll just i'll just stick to answering
the questions that i've written down
um so let me just
okay so we had a question
in relation to the construction site
management plan and where the details
have been provided
um actually some details have been
provided in in a construction site
management plan have been submitted with
the application
but actually we've got a very um
substantial condition
recommended which would require precise
details of that to be agreed
um prior to uh commencement of the
development on site
um in relation to wildlife um
uh badger sets um are quite protected
um by law so what i'm not proposing to
do is point out
where exactly they are on the plan but
what i will say
is that there are a number of existing
badger sets
on the site um and the applicant has
submitted an ecology report
which assesses um the proposed
development in relation to those in
detail
um we have gone to a consulting at essex
county council
to get advice in relation to that
ecology report
and some conditions have been um
recommended to be imposed
so there is a condition in relation to
the badger set
which requires um a license from natural
england
because of their level of protection
um so that license will need to be
obtained before development commences
and it will mean that um any development
in and around the sets
is tightly controlled under that license
a couple of the sets are proposed to be
closed um temporarily during
construction work but again that's
managed under the license so it would
have to be agreed by natural england
um i think some sets would be
closed permanently but the larger sets
would remain
open um so they would be accommodated
within the layout
um and it also there'd be a requirement
for some habitat
improvement um within areas so that the
set would link
um to the sort of wider green space
towards the eastern side
further wildlife enhancement is also
proposed so
by condition the developer would be
required to install a number of bat
boxes
and bird boxes um they would also be
required to
take account of lighting scheme to the
site would have to take account of
um bats so that's that's in particular
light sort of low level lighting that
would be required
to ensure that pedestrians um
let me just share my screen with you so
so in relation to the bats um hopefully
you can see the layout plan on sweden
and my cursor indicating but
um what we do require what we would
require is some low-level lighting so
that
the footpath um that's created in the
eastern part of the site
is usable you know in the winter times
for pedestrians and it's safe
like a nice environment for for users
but that lighting would have to take
account of
impact on bats as would any lighting
along this um
green corridor east east-west as well
there is also a requirement by condition
for a reptile mitigation strategy across
the site
so those wildlife
concerns and have been considered in
detail
and conditions are required as necessary
in relation to electric vehicle charging
points there is a condition
um i uh
could take you to the number if you need
so if you want me to do that please
please come back
but there is a requirement for some
provision of electric vehicle charging
points at the site
um then we had another question
in relation to the specifically in
relation to the cycle lane
so what i'm proposing to show you
is if i just stop the share for a moment
just going to bring up
some more photographs because i think
this will make
this this clearer
okay i'm going to share my screen again
okay so hopefully members on screen what
you can see now is another
picture so slightly different one to the
one before so this is on ashington road
looking north
and what it shows is the existing
segregated cycle and pedestrian
um lanes that run north towards
the the crossing opposite the school
so if i just scroll down
we get to the sorry it's a bit too far
um
so this is the photo that was previously
shown in my presentation
so the photo just above got to this
point here
where my cursor is then cyclists
required to dismount
cross the road and what happens at
present
is then the cycle
lane could start again at approximately
where my cursor is here
so it's not immediately after the
crossing but
it's not too far away so then you get a
segregated cycle
and pedestrian lanes again heading north
um but on the opposite side of the road
okay
and then and then this is again further
north looking back in a
southerly direction um so this um
segregated cycle and pedestrian lane
then is extending from approximately
this point here where my cursor is
um northwards okay and it runs along you
know
past the uh site the boundary with the
hulk farm
schools um continuing northward
so if i then take you back to the phase
one layout plan
um and i might just zoom in slightly
hopefully this is
clear um so i'm in this
bottom left-hand corner of my screen
with the cursor
so the photographs i've just shown you
show that the existing
segregated cycle and pedestrian lanes
are coming northbound
um and then you'd cross at the same
point
but um the crossing would be upgraded
and then it's this section so from this
point here where my cursor is
to this black box indicated my curse
here at approximately this point
it's that section that because of the
narrowed
um pedestrian sort of cycle
the narrowing of this area here as a
result of the widening of the
carriageway
um you'd have a shared space so
cyclists would have to dismount and push
the cycle up to this point here
at which they could carry on on the um
the segregated
um pedestrian cycle lanes
so i hope that makes that point clear in
relation to the
to the impact we're looking at in terms
of the widening of the carriageway
on the cycling um
and what um we did have another comment
i think from councillor fd about um
the cycle link to watchful town centre
and the contributions
um i don't have specific details about
what those contributions would be put
towards um
but it's a significant contribution of
250
000 pounds towards cycle upgrades and so
that would be to be agreed with them
county highways and i think
um but please correct me if i'm wrong
chairman if i've missed any specific
questions other than that
um i think we've covered uh
sufficient there if you could unshare
the screen again
please um
just before we progress any further
members
in order to ensure completion of
this item tonight i move that the
meeting be extended beyond
the standard two and a half um
hours that were nor we normally have
could i just ask
councillor eaves and councillor shaw to
take down their hands please
can i now ask for those members in favor
of extending the meeting beyond
the two and a half hours to please
indicate
that's all members have agreed to that
thank you if you could
would mind wouldn't mind dropping your
hands please
chairman could i just say that i did ask
specific questions
that haven't been answered
if you just want to mention them again
then please quickly
because i do we do need to move on the
uh
two-lane approach to the roundabouts on
the current designs
uh could uh someone give me an answer on
how much of an improvement they expect
to be and the hundred thousand pounds
towards upgrades
on the the ann berlin roundabout there
is no detailing on that at all hundred
thousand pounds we should be able to see
something
thank you
karen did you want me to come in yeah
just uh yeah do those quickly and then
fine move on so um
in relation to the first question about
how much improvement there would be
expected from the junction improvements
um proposed
um i don't have any sort of specific
figures um provided what we do have is
county essex county council high risk
authority having looked at
the initial transport assessment that
came in and the addendum
and being satisfied that the junction
improvements
um that are proposed and would be
required um by the section 106 agreement
um would give sufficient um improvement
such that the impacts on on the network
wouldn't be severe
but i i can't give you any any more
detail than that
um obviously my colleague from county
and hillary gore
is is available so and we might hear
from her shortly i think
um in relation to the amber injunction
improvements again
um we i haven't got any specific and
detail
about what those junction improvements
would be um it'd be a hund it'd be a
substantial contribution
and it will be for essex county council
highways to to agree
what what best junction improvements
would
um provide the best um improvement
in that area thank you i'm going to come
back to councillor wilkinson
now uh councillor wilkinson um i've
given everyone the ability to have
um a a description of their
their concerns and thoughts we've we've
clearly covered the breadth and the
depth of
of this application um but i i did say
that
you would have the opportunity to come
back so given
everything that you've heard would you
now like to uh
speak again please chairman um
yes it's interesting to hear everybody's
thoughts um
i my my recommendation for
the motion of mood stands chairman um
and
the the the reason that i that i say
that as opposed to deferment which is
what i'm talking about so that's
the first thing because there's been two
issues there's been two recommendations
that have been muted tonight one is
deferment one's
refusal the reason i i'm going with
refusal is because
the reasons for firm that i've heard
from members who have spoken is around
the traffic assessments um and getting
independent
uh traffic assessments done and and and
i fully support that
i do fully support that and and how that
would be integrated into a decision
tonight by us and by the officers i
don't know and i'll take advice on that
but i do
okay i would not change my i i'm just
going to have to
on your reasons for refusal yeah i'm
going to
have to ask you to be very precise about
yeah sure
your your reasons rather than relying on
the officers
okay oh no fair enough okay well at this
moment in time
um my reasons for refusal are i don't
think the traffic
um assessment that's been done is is is
sufficient and i think the impact on the
traffic
uh in the area not just ashington but i
don't think the whole of this district
can cope with anymore and i think that
the
the um uh the recommendations from
county
don't add up as far as i'm concerned
when you look at some of the the
remodeling some of the roundabouts
is not sufficient the access point uh
is completely wrong that access point
cannot happen and i cannot support this
application without access points in
that location
at all could you just go into a little
bit more detail in that please
i think okay um i think it's it's
uh the the the widening of the road um
is having a detrimental effect on uh
a number of things first of all it's
taking away that tree
which i think is a is a tragedy it's
it's
narrowing the pavement outside of hulk
farm school
which is completely opposite to what i
think you should be doing if anything
you should be
protecting the children the parents
outside you know being a parent myself i
stand outside of school for my children
and i wouldn't want that area narrowing
um so i think that's wrong um and
and i don't think ashington road itself
can cope uh with it i don't think that
the action will need to be another um
another uh access point
explored i think it's over development
to the site
chairman um this site was put aside for
500 houses
um the s policy scr8
um has got two conditions for the uplift
of five percent and they have not been
satisfied in my submission at all so
it's
non-compliant with that policy um
the density is too much it should be 30
per hectare it's 33.1
um it is pure over development of the
sites and
furthermore chair um how this will get
recorded i i'm not sure but
furthermore i would submit that the the
whole basis that we're relying on
or the developers relying on for this
submission is the fact that this
loss of land is within the adopted local
plan that adopt a local plan
is not compliant because it's not being
reviewed in
in compliance with the town and country
planning act unless the officer can tell
me otherwise
so therefore um it's not been updated
not being reviewed so how do we know
that it's still fit for purpose
um so those are my reasons for
recommending refusal jim
second the motion for refusal
okay right before we have any further
discussion on this
i'm going to go back to offices um and
then we will be focusing our discussion
specifically around the the proposed and
seconded reason for refusal
so first of all um if katie would you
like to come back
on this yes thank you chair so we've
just for clarity the the reasons that
are put forward
uh that the traffic um impact assessment
um is flawed that the access point is
detrimental
uh the the removal of the tree the
pavement narrowing
uh is problematical
the site uh being over developed
and that the conditions within sr8 scr8
are not satisfied and the fitness of the
adopted local
plan so they're the items we're talking
to thank you
yeah thank you uh additions to the
no not at this moment cancer reeves
thank you chairman um so if i'd comment
on um
they've been presented in slightly
different order i'll comment on the over
development
um point first
so i think we would need to be clear in
any reason for refusal about what the
adverse impacts
of the development are in the respective
over development
so maybe if i just um uh clarify that
further um so for instance
if the site at 662 dwellings would
result in dwellings with garden areas
falling significantly
significantly short of the minimum
policy requirement or
if the minimum parking provision could
not be achieved etcetera then
in those sort of circumstances and with
that clarification
um an over development reason for
refusal um
would make sense um but in this respect
in terms of those two items that i've
just mentioned in terms of amenity space
and parking
actually this development would comply
so i think what we definitely need is
clarity on what the you know the effects
um the the um
the adverse impacts are i think just
mentioning that the site is over
developed is not enough um we need more
in relation to a reason
for refusal around over development um
in relation to um
the highway impacts so that that has
been um clarified
a bit so we're talking about the traffic
assessment not being sufficient
um impact of traffic in the area being
too much so it
adverse impact on the local highway
network um
the mppf requires that
the the test is essentially that would
have to be met is that
the residual cumulative residual
cumulative impact on the local highway
network would have to be considered
severe so
what we are left with is that essex
county council highways authority have
considered
the transport assessment and do not
support that reason for refusal
and what the council will be required to
provide on appeal
is evidence that the impacts would be
severe
so the applicant's submitted data
doesn't support that
the applicant's um transport assessment
does identify that there will be a
residual impact but not that it would be
severe
what i might um like to do at this point
chairman
unless you want me to go through my
concerns in relation to
or my points in relation to all the
reasons for refusal that have been
um tabled would you prefer to bring
hillary in in relation to the highways
now um yeah yes yes so i think hillary
it would be good to just hear from essex
from your perspective as essex county
council in relation to a reason for
refusal around any sort of
um impact adverse impact on the local
highway network
and also perhaps you could cover um the
safety points in relation to the
proposed access into the site in
relation to highways
thank you chairman yes i will cover them
um
that there are a number of highway
points that have been raised um
one one is is the impact i think it's
important to
let you know that um the applicant has
prepared
the um traffic impact assessment and the
traffic um
transport assessment addendum and we
actually do an independent review of
that data
and it's it's our job to assess that and
just make sure
that it is a robust a robust assessment
and has been carried out in accordance
with industry standards
um to make sure that we um
are happy with with any impact on the
road network
your members are correct that not all
the impact can
be mitigated with um
improvements on the highway network the
summer junctions that can rotary road
ashington road can be and dalys road
ashlington road can be
as we've heard one one of the questions
on the recreate
junction was will the
implementation of two lanes actually
work the answer is
we have every confidence that it will
work because the capacity analysis
shows very very clearly that without
those improvements it would be well over
capacity
and with the improvements um it brings
it back to
roughly about the same as it is you know
without development um
and that there's no reason there's no
site constraints
which means that the two lanes wouldn't
actually work some some junctions
there are lots of site constraints like
very tight bends or
very specific site issues which means
that the two lanes aren't actually used
there's nothing like this at the retro
road junction which would suggest that
the two lanes wouldn't be used
and therefore um you know we would
expect that um
the capacity improvements would be
realized in line with
what the um transport assessment
predicts um
with regard to the hall road junction we
acknowledge that's a very very difficult
junction
and the modeling um again just follows
industry standards for modeling
in terms of the um
the fact that um that the modeling is is
is said to be unstable when it reaches
capacity
yes that's recognized it doesn't mean to
say that the model shouldn't be used
absolutely it should be used the model
shows that it will be
at or over capacity at times
particularly peak times
um but what it actually does mean is
that the
the lengths of the cues aren't actually
realistic because
um when when you reach capacity with a
model it just
exponentially adds traffic to the back
of the queue so in some circumstances
it'll show
you know maybe 200 vehicles in the back
of the queue which actually won't be
realized
because people will um change their
modes of transport
um they you know they they will
potentially um
travel at different times they're not
going to be sitting at the back of a 20
vehicle queue for 20 minutes they'll
they'll
either decide that they'll they'll make
a trip by different means
they will um travel maybe half an hour
earlier
they maybe get the bus then maybe use a
different route
and therefore all that modelling means
why it's unstable is that you can't
actually rely on it going to be
20 vehicles 100 vehicles 200 vehicles in
the queue once it gets over that that
capacity threshold um
i would caution against doing your own
independent
transport assessment because basically
as a county council authority as i said
we do an independent assessment
we make sure that the assessment is
robust
we have had numerous iterations and
numerous discussions negotiations
with the applicants highway consultants
to make sure that that the assessment
they have done is robust assessment
it's very unlikely that any independent
um consultant would come up
with anything different because all the
industry standard tools have been used
the temporal for the growth
the distribution um the traffic
generation we've made sure they use the
highest rates it's very robust
assessment we've
sent them away to do more work as you
know that's why we've had various
situations and the addendum
um and in the past um we've had other
district authorities
um commission their own transport
assessment
only to um realize that that um
that we as a as a highway authority
have come to the right conclusions
because there's nowhere else to go and
it ends up being very very time
consuming very expensive
and it actually doesn't lead to any
different conclusions so i'll just
caution against that it's totally your
choice whether you do that but i would
caution against doing that
because we we do um carry out our very
own
thorough independent checks um it's not
it's not our modelling it we
we check it very very very thoroughly um
in terms of there was some very
site-specific questions
about um the amberlynn roundabout being
contribution
of a hundred thousand pounds towards
that the reason we're taking a
contribution
is because any works there are likely to
be major works as you know it's very
constrained at the moment
there's lots of statutory undertaker's
plans including
um overhead um statutory undertaker's
plant
uh which are probably going to be
underground very soon which gives the
potential to do some um significant
improvements there
we've already got some contributions
from other developments
around about the area in vicinity of the
south end airport
which we will put together um to do a
comprehensive um improvement scheme
um 100 000 pounds will go towards that
it won't pay for all of it
but um you know putting all the
contributions together we should be able
to do something substantial there
at the moment um we haven't got any
detailed design of that because
it's very early stages there's lots of
statutory undertaker's work to do
before that and therefore the detailed
design will be carried out
um following that um
more um collection of more contributions
and
um the safety undertaker's work um but
it will be an
essex county council scheme um
is there anything else chairman that
you'd like me to answer i think
if uh katie you would like to continue
now please
thank you chair um
in relation to um
density um
policy sets out a minimum density of 30
dwellings per hectare
and the requirement is that kind of best
use
of land um is achieved and the density
proposed would not be significantly
greater
than the 30 dwellings per hectare and
members would
need to be very clear about why the
density is unacceptable
so what is the adverse impact that would
result
so offices for instance consider that
the design and layout
which has been shown on the plans on
screen
in the presentation would be appropriate
to the locality
so i would have to advise that it would
not be
sufficient to simply state in a reason
for refusal
and that the proposed density would be
objectionable in principle
we would have to get you know narrow
you know go a bit deeper to understand
um what it is
um what's the adverse impact resulting
and that that's what a you know if if
this was a reason for refusal
it's the about the adverse impacts that
the um an inspector would want to
interrogate
um on appeal um in relation to
um scr eight policy which is the site
allocation policy
um and
we would need to be again clear about
exactly which bits of that policy
um we're suggesting that the proposal
would not accord with
um i know and then further it has been
referenced that it wouldn't accord with
that part
um that allows for a greater number of
dwellings but only in certain
circumstances
so those certain circumstances are the
five-year housing land supply not being
met
and an under provision in the locality
set out in the offices report is the
fact that
um in this circumstance the five-year
housing
supply is not is not met and
those policies could be considered in
relation to housing numbers
to be somewhat out of date so it sets
out clearly in the officer report that
in those circumstances the national
policy is clear
that applications must be determined um
in relation to a certain paragraph
within the
national planning policy framework
section 11 d and that requires
that adverse impacts of the development
would have to be would have to
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits
in order for a refusal
um the same i think it was also termed
the local plan
reference to the local plan not being
valid anymore again i'd
i'd go back so in terms of if any
policies are out of date
it's that part of the mppf that members
are required to determine this
application in relation to
so this weighing exercise of the adverse
impact
have to cl significantly and
demonstrably outweigh all of the
benefits
um of the scheme in terms of the
delivery of housing
affordable housing on an allocated site
in terms of the local the plan being out
of date as well i would
just mention um
there is me so the core strategy and
allocation plan were adopted several
years ago
now but they are forward planning
documents
and policy scr8 identifies that this
site would be safeguarded from
development until 2021
so if you like it was always envisaged
that the development of this site would
be at about this point in time
so to be talking about housing being
delivered um
next year in 2021 at the earliest so in
that in that respect
this policy is not out of date um
and i think that covers
all of the can all of the reasons um my
comments in relation to all of the
reasons
thank you were any of the other officers
wanting to just
make a comment at this stage
jim i'm not on a point of order could i
request a comfort break
uh bearing in mind that we are at 10
o'clock
right i'll take that in in just a moment
um so the way we will pursue this
next council will concern
i will ask you to um
re restate and reconfirm your reasons
for refusal
and then we will have a debate
specifically around those points
but i think members have indicated
that uh just on a on a show of hands
if we take a a a three or four minute
break
just trying to show our hands those
members are content with that
yeah okay i will briefly adjourn the
minute
the the meeting for three or four
minutes thank you
i believe
all right we're all back yeah
i think then i can restart
okay i'll reconvene uh the meeting
um first i would just like um
uh yvonne dunn uh to speak first please
thank you chair thank you um good
evening members
um i just want to uh follow up on
the follow-up from katie on the
suggested reasons for refusal
um if i just take the point on the local
plan policies being
out of date um and if i can refer to
a high court judgment in 2019
where the lord justice dove actually
said that there's
nothing in the relevant provisions in
the framework to suggest that the
expiration of a plan period requires
that his policies should be treated as
out of date
and indeed the contrary the provisions
of paragraph
213 specifically contemplate that older
policies which
are consistent with the framework should
be afforded continuing weight
so just to elaborate on katie's point
ser 8
is an allocation and was considered to
be brought forward
in 2021 so the local plan is not out of
date
um if we can just pick up on the
highways the concerns about the highways
relating and not supported by the
technical data in the transport
assessment which has been scrutinized by
the highway authority
which resulted in a further addendum to
the original transport assessment
furthermore no concerns related to the
site entrance on washington road have
been made
by highways authority and as your
officers
and as the highways authority have also
advised you a reason for refusal on
highways grounds would be extremely
difficult to defend
um and then the latter point on over
development
allocation scr8 has the capacity to
provide a minimum
of 500 dwellings at a density of 30
dwellings per hectare
the government direct planning
authorities through the framework on the
efficient use of land
and as we've heard from the officer this
evening the development
proposes uh 33.1
dwellings per hectare this this is
not um you know this is not over
development
um this this density provides the
one and two bedroom properties that are
required
uh by people that live in our district
um to buy for their first properties or
indeed
downsize so i just wanted to you know
just
offer those that advice um to members
when they're considering those reasons
for refusal
thank you and mr hotton please
thank you chair i um i guess it's almost
reiterating what's already been said
i mean there have been um listen to the
sort of the views of members
there are i guess many valid concerns
um understandable concerns around this
uh and and you are reflecting many of
the resident voices that we've noted
um my concern i guess is that the
committee
are bound by law um to make a decision
in accordance with the local plan
and uh taking into account material
planning considerations
um so i'm hearing from katie that what
she's politely saying is that she's not
hearing enough from you
in terms of what those material
considerations actually are
at this stage uh excuse me what you're
going is
against you're going contrary to um the
professional advice
which has been i guess built upon those
material considerations
and and so katie has asked you to give a
more specific
i guess um clarity around those because
the inspector would require those
in that sense i think um if there's if
there's still a lack of clarity
um then i understand there was a another
motion i think put forth by
councilwoman's
around deferment perhaps will be
explored further which allows
a comprehensive advice and further
research if required
but i said but i will leave it at this
stage thank you thank you
councillor wilkinson you've heard the
professional advice you've heard
as you mentioned the discussion you put
forward the
one two three four five five specific
points for refusal
would you now would would you care
care to comment or reconfirm
please uh but but ideally
if it is to reconfirm we do the officers
have requested some
greater clarity thank you
okay thank you cher um we seem to be
odds don't we
because um everybody
in the room they seem to be divided on
one side of the fence or the other
there's nobody sitting on the fence um
and i
also hear and listen to what uh yvonne
said about the local plan and she's the
high court judgment
nobody's mentioned what i said about the
town and country planning act clearly
states that we should have done
something so
whilst the high court may will say well
that's me to say you can ignore the
policy
fair enough but we haven't complied with
the law because we haven't reviewed it
you know so it's have your heavy cake
and eat it by the sounds of it
um chair i i stand by my
motion for refusal um
and because i will not support this at
all um
if we need to dig down a little bit more
into make to making sure that we get
this right
then i'm happy to do that i can only
tell you what my views are
um i think that when it comes to over
development
um you know we're here we hear that the
local plan says
you know it's it's set aside for at
least 500 houses
at 30 houses per hectare but that's been
stretched to 662 houses
um with 33.1 houses per hectare to the
point where
the community space has to be put
outside of the
the the border for stras it's actually
on greenbelt lands i think the
the the allotments and um i can't
remember what the other thing is
are actually outside of the actual
allocated land now
you know if that's not a development if
the there is an allocated space
fit it inside if you can't because
you're putting too many houses in
then that's the reason why you're
putting too many houses in i think that
the
the the number of houses there will have
a detrimental effect on the highway
i hear what hillary gault says and
i personally prepare to take uh would be
stupid not to take her advice
uh i think it's sound advice that
perhaps an independent
traffic assessment would come up with
the same uh results
um she's the expert in the area however
um i'm not going to ignore the impact
this is going to have
on the local community um the that's
that junction
is in my view not fit for purpose um i
stand by
my comments about the safety to the
parents and children outside holt farm
school
um i think that's entirely wrong it's
entirely wrong location
and i can't put it any other way i can't
give you a policy or anything else all i
can say to you is what i feel
it's in the wrong location um it needs
to be somewhere else i accept like i
think most members accept here
that that plan that that site rather is
at some point going to get developed
um i don't think there's a sadly i don't
think there's much we can do about it i
don't agree with it but i don't think
there's much we can do about it but in
this current form i cannot accept this
application
in its current form um for the reasons
that i've given you
okay thank you very much uh cancer mrs
shaw you seconded this would you care to
say any more yeah thank you chair um
i do support it and considering the
reasons for refusal i've taken into
account the following
we've got to look at the pedestrian
safety this was mentioned
when we debated it this i do think
we need as a point why we refuse this
application
also the planning practice guidance
which was published in 2014
enforces the mppf commitment requiring
good designs
this is about creating places building
and spaces that will work well for
everyone
they should look good last one i will
adapt
to the needs of future generations i do
not think
this does the mppf
and the subsequent publication the
planning guidance in march
was replaced has replaced the planning
policy statements
the following design guidance still are
relevant to
creating good design and that is a
reason for refusal
thank you thank you um
right so we we fully understand the
reasons for refusal as they've been
stated katie
uh one more comment from you and then
any other members that wish mr speaker
to this motion we'll go from there thank
you
thank you chairman um sorry i'm not
entirely clear but
perhaps you could it might be a very
easy answer is
are the reasons for refusal essentially
those
same five as before um
i'm i still would um urge caution in
relation to a reason refusal around over
development
when the specific harm
has not yet been identified so i unders
reasons for refusal around
overdevelopment often and can be
appropriate
but i think a reason for refusal has to
include
um specifically identifying the harm
that would be caused
um so that's the only um point to have
in relation to that
um i think we've already mentioned our
concerns around
um what evidence the council would do
just for the sake of clarity to break
this down i can't
i can cancel
wilkinson as the proposer you just need
to be clear on that please yeah
okay well hopefully we're on the same
page um well yes i mean
i i've given some reasons for it which
is the the the fact that we've
we're going outside the boundary of the
of the actually allocated plan
um but also it's the additional every
single part of this traffic assessment
states the severe impacts is going to
have on the road network
okay it hasn't in my view and this is
why i think it's not fit
but i accept i've listened to what
hillary has had to say
there's been a complete um completely
ignored the fact that where this is
situated with regards to
the fact that we're on a peninsula and
the wider road network i don't think
it's been considered
but we can't just ignore there's an
extra 162 homes gonna be built
with a minimum of an extra 162 cars
probably more
you know that's going to have an adverse
impact on the road network
okay every single additional house is
built will have an adverse impact on the
road network because
it's extra cars on the road okay so
but the fewer houses that are built the
less the impact on the road network
um they can't do anything to the
roundabout at
the station uh hall road and uh
ashington road
um so the least i can do then is to
build fewer houses and minimize the
impact there
does that go somewhere to help you katie
okay
thank you um i think we're
we're starting to get towards the
conclusion um counselor stanley
you you indicated you you you know the
motion that we're talking to
uh and it's those specific points either
in support of them or against them
please
yes thank you chairman um yes i
i i would like to point out that the
the there's over development in the way
of uh
on to uh green green belt uh uh
to emphasize that please but at the same
time i didn't get my questions answered
by katie rogers thank you
thank you care counselor
thank you chair in support of the um
uh the proposed junction the approved uh
the um
objection to that um
it's not providing a healthy and safe
environment in accordance with the nppf
that is further report from essex county
council
growth development team and that is
listed in the report from kt
and paragraph 4.54 so that should be
added
to the list in support of the
safety issue there are a number of
issues that have been brought up within
the conversation
uh that have actually given good reasons
for refusal to be added i don't know if
no we're we are where we are with this
one at the moment we've got a
uh a motion for refusal which has been
properly seconded so that
that's the item we're speaking to now
it's just that we are told that we have
to
put everything in that we can if there
is likely to be a refusal
that's what we are doing training
we're we're talking to this specific
motion at the moment
okay right um
so the way we'll run it from now is i
shall
ask the officers to
sum up where we are to give members
their
advice counselor wilkinson will then
restate
we will then go to the vote the final
speaker
before the officers restate and do that
process
is councillor hookway who's talking to
the motion that's put forward in front
of us
you chairman i'm sorry counselor that's
the hot way
thank you chairman um yes we're talking
to
the motion before us um but as members
of this committee
we are also in a position
to offer um advice to
the member putting forward the motion
and
the possibility of also asking for
amendment to that motion or any
additions to
to the motion to make it um
more solid we don't want to vote on
something
which is uh um is weak
and it's going to cause us problems um
uh in future so i think that what
countries was suggesting
was to make some
possibility of uh adding or amending the
motion
so that it makes it much more um
uh solid um so you know um
i think that uh that's that's what
we need to to consider um
and i think that um having an
independent traffic assessment
uh as part of the motion would help
uh back up the issues around
safety around the
the road junction and the crossing in
relation to the schools
so comprehensive traffic assessment
of the area would be an appropriate uh
addition to the motion also
the fact that this
application as it stands doesn't meet
our requirement as part of our original
local plan
uh in relation to this site for um
youth facilities on the site um
that is not within uh the application
and that is therefore something that
also should be raised
as part of strengthening uh the motion
to make sure that it covers that area as
well
are you are you putting forward an
amendment to the motion council
clarity what what your amendment is
well i'd like a comprehensive traffic
independent traffic assessment to look
at
issues around traffic
and safety in relation to concerns
raised about the safety of the uh
the access point in relation to um the
schools
uh pedestrians not just not just uh road
users but pedestrians as well and
also um i think that
the the application as it stands
doesn't meet uh our requirements as part
of our local plan
for uh youth facilities to be to be
provided
within uh the site as as originally
uh stated in our local plan um
there is also um the issue of part of
the
the the traffic survey should also look
at the element
of pollution as well so whether that is
made within
uh the the survey or as a separate
survey around about pollution to do with
traffic
that uh that should also be added
thank you i'm somewhat concerned what
you've said about
independent trafficker assessment and
inclusion
there those are actions that you want
taken they're not reasons for refusal of
the
application that's that's down in front
of us
um
can i ask is there anyone that is happy
to second
council hookway on those actions
yeah i'll second that counselor wilson
right can i ask um
katie to um pass comment on
on on those um
those amendments thank you chairman so
just in relation to the amendments um
i'm concerned
um as you've just indicated that um
two of those items talk about um
requiring
a further assessment in relation to
transport and air quality
and that it would not be appropriate to
put that
as a requirement into a reason for
refusal because
essentially we don't know what those
assessments might conclude
and they may well conclude like there's
a possibility they may conclude
that actually um that the harm that
members
are identifying in relation to impact on
the local highway network and
and now air quality um you know that
that wouldn't be
um concluded um from these further
independent assessments
in which case the reasons for refusal
would fall away if you like
so i i don't think it would be
appropriate for any reason for refusal
to
to include any requirement for an
assessment
um i think a requirement for some sort
of
other assessment or further
consideration needs to be separate
from any reason for refusal okay okay uh
it's done please
apologies okay um yes i mean basically
um we ca as officers we can certainly
revisit those points and seek further
sort of comprehensive guidance on
obtaining additional
information um and then bring that back
to committee but that would be
um deferring the item tonight
um and you know just on the although i
did mention the reasons for refusal
before i just want to
sort of respectfully sort of advise
members that
you know having sat in numerous planning
appeals public inquiries and informal
hearings
the inspector when he is looking at an
appeal which
you know obviously we've got to accept
that if we refuse this application
tonight
we are quite likely to have to take this
to appeal
the inspector can only look at the
information that he has in front of him
which is the information that's here
tonight in front of members and as we've
heard
there has been no objection from the
highway authority
their officers do not consider that
there's an issue with over development
and as we've heard there is no
problem with the actual validity of the
council's local plan
so um you know i just feel that as
officers we should be advising
members tonight that um
you know refusing the application
could be you know quite difficult for
the council to defend later at an appeal
okay mr hotton
i think uh von dunham has just addressed
it really and that's the concern around
that um
as you say this is something that's been
put forward um by officers
um for recommendation uh and therefore i
think it will be
um uh quite a conflict for them to
defend at an appeal situation
and i think that's why we're trying to
answer very specific reasons for refusal
because those are very taken forward um
officers have no reason to
of refuse of their own to offer so it's
really for members to have drawn those
out
and to be legally robust i think that's
what i'm concerned at the moment is i'm
not hearing
of reasons that are materially sound
enough
uh to be defended by officers
comfortably and i wonder if a deferment
is more
um a suitable route at this stage just
so we can
have some sort of a further advice on
this and and to gain some survival a
comprehensive
view of the options available thank you
uh councillor hookway um you've heard
the officer's specific advice around
your request for additional um
assessments um the
the substantive one within what you said
was
the requirement for youth facilities not
being met
i noticed that um there hasn't been any
officer comment on relation to that
and so therefore that's obviously
something which is appropriate
okay so um that would be an appropriate
amendment to the um
to the motion okay members are going to
try with regard to the
trafficker survey maybe that's something
that we
might be able to seek as an advisement
not a reason thank you
okay i'm going to break this down um
we've got the um we've got the emotion
for an amen or an amendment
to include in the reasons for refusal
the
requirement for youth facilities not
being met
so we will deal with that one first um
putting that with the substantive motion
um on that specific item counselor
stanley your hand is up
do you want to speak about youth
facilities
i really wanted to say that uh perhaps
the amendment should also put in the
the we've we've got to be we're going to
break this down really clearly
and also the the the the facilities that
youth facilities are on there
in in the hands of the nhs the area that
we're talking about so that doesn't
that doesn't meet our requirements
okay all right members
um can i please first
ask you to raise your hand if you
require
a recorded vote on the amendment
with regard regarding youth facilities
okay that threshold is passed
there'll now be a recorded vote on that
there are four members indicating
so please indicate whether you are
for or against the inclusion
of the amendment on youth facilities
councillor eves
apologies chairman i put my hand up
because i was uh voting on the
uh this is a recorded vote so we have to
do this one
um right by roll call
so uh yes i agree with the amendment
councillor williams
thank you chairman no against the
amendment thank you council stanley
yes please that four against
four four four that's the fd
for the amendment chairman that's the
against councillor gooding
for the amendment chairman councillor
mrs shaw
for the amendment that's the butcher
for the amendment thank you chairman
that's the wilkinson
for the amendment tree councillor
hawkway
for the amendment chairman councilman mr
shaw
for the amendment thank you chairman
myself against
councillor wilson for the amendment
just uh
need to confirm so i've got three
against ten four
i was just looking for sonia to nod
ahead
yes um that that amendment is now
included so i come
i now move back to yourself councillor
wilkinson
um you've stated your one two three
four five reasons for
refusal the officers have requested
greater clarity there is now an
additional reason for refusal
regarding the youth facility assessment
you have had also heard the officer's
request
that for for greater clarity and their
thought that deferment
might be a way forward to sit to help
understand the clarity
of the um what what you've been talking
about
so would you would you just like to
reconfirm your position please
you're just muted yeah sorry my position
hasn't changed jim
okay so as we were saying before we will
just
go to the final officer statement
then the restate uh then the restatement
of the reasons for refusal
then to the vote will this be recorded
chairman please
uh we haven't we haven't got to that
element yet to cancer stanley
um katie is there anything further that
you wish
to say yes please chairman so
um i think we need absolute clarity
about the reasons for refusal and i know
i think you're going to invite
councillor
wilkinson to restate them um but if i
could just comment
i think that the um council hookways
motion that was carried to introduce the
um
concern that youth facilities would be
provided within the green belt space
rather than within the um site
allocation has actually all
is actually i think was already
mentioned by councillor wilkinson
in terms of his his um over development
point about the um the use of the
greenback land if
if you like in addition so i'm not sure
that it's a separate reason for refusal
um
i think um in councillor wilkinson's um
clarification the over development point
in
in relation to the harm where i i
sort of pushed to say we need to
identify what the harm is
i think the over development point is
actually linked um
to the impact on the local highway
network
so unless i'm i'm wrong what i
understood from councillor wilkinson
is that his concern is that the number
of dwellings proposed
would be harmful in the respect that it
would have a more
significant impact on the local highway
network so
that's the harm i've heard being
identified
i haven't heard any other harm but if
there is um if you could make that clear
um that would be helpful um
the other and then the other ones i had
was to do with the safety
of the junction in terms of the
narrowing of the footwear
um for parents and children that reason
for refusal also included reference to
the loss of the tree
originally but i'd like clarification
about whether that
is still to be included um i
i there's sort of potentially two
reasons around
referring to um inconsistency with
policy
scr8 and the development plan being out
of date
i think if you could provide just a bit
of clarity as to whether they're two
separate reasons for refusal or
or or not um and oh wait my question is
are we consid are we still
um council wilkins then proposing a
reason for refusal around
inappropriate density because if we are
i'm still
not sure about what the harm is in
relation to the density proposed
which is just um not significantly
above the 30 dwellings per hectare and i
think we would need to be clear about
what that harm is
okay uh thank you
does uh yvonne or marx hotham either you
want to come back
i mean i think we i do feel like we're
i'm so it's coming like groundhog day
but i think we are we are coming back
down to the nobody and that is
but um the reasons being put forward do
not seem
uh in planning terms um material
considerations
and you know um and that is our concern
we can only advise
um and so we hear what members are
saying but i think from our point of
view
um should um this be mine to be refused
now two deferral is gone as an option um
at that point um i would expect
although there's a strong possibility
that law homes would consider an appeal
um i think as officers i think what
we're trying to say is we will struggle
to defend that
appeal for you with the reasons that you
have put forward and i think that that's
that's where
we're at at the moment so there is a
concern that
if this does go that it will be hard to
defend at appeal
and so my only concern would be at this
stage would be to consider a deferral so
we can at least get further advice
and allow comprehensive advice on this
matter
so all members can take view of that
before arriving as a final decision
and that's what i would ask you to
consider very seriously
um there is no rush to arrive at the
decision this evening
uh you know um if there are aspects i
think as officers we are finding we are
hard
to um define this evening i think that
that's a bit of a warning sign for you
but perhaps we do need to get that
further clarity before we actually
arrive at the decision
so i i respectfully ask that you do
consider possibly uh the option of
deferral as something that may be a
better way forward
so at least we have some more time to
discuss it i get i guess with further
um wider views of the impact of the
decision thank you
through the chair i'd actually put
through uh pedestrian safety and that
hasn't been mentioned okay
sure please don't interrupt
members we've got to progress the
meeting we have had
the motion put forward there's a number
of hands popping up but we're starting
to go around the houses
so it we're moving to the motion
depending on
council
your reasons for refusal with this
motion
unless you do wish to if i'd like to
make i'd like to make a point chair
through you if it's okay
um i think my position on this is quite
clear
i'm not happy with it however i do
respect the officers of this council
and i wish we'd be stupid to ignore them
and listen to what marcus and casey and
yvonne are saying
um i'm not going to ignore what they're
saying at all i need to ask a question
here um the way this currently stands i
can't support it and i can't and i've
told you the reasons why
i do think it's so development i i am
concerned about the the
the uh the impact on the road network
that junction is just wrong in every
sense of the word the loss of the tree
the safety to the children outside the
school the parents and everything else
but i do want to make sure that we get
this right
um and and i and and i'm not trying to
do a u-turn or anything far from it
i i will never support this in its
current form but i do want to make sure
that we are in a position to be able to
defend this properly
so i'm happy to take advice as to
what a deferment would actually achieve
if we were
to go for a line because we've got three
options we either defer
reject or approve well i'm not going to
approve it so
what's what's the benefit are we going
to get from actually
from a deferment well i mean i think
it's quite clear to the three officers
i'm looking at now that
they know what my concerns are they know
what most members here concerns are
tonight
what would a deferment actually achieve
to allay those fears
i'm going to ask mr harton to come back
on this one
in all honesty um it may not allow your
fears
in that sense um but there are also
risks going forward so
um there's more ones i mean this is all
scenarios if you like so
um if we uh reminded to refuse tonight
and it went to appeal then
and there was uh as you're as you're
hearing tonight the officers are
concerned they can't defend this
um and so um at this stage
we can't be sure but there there is a a
possibility distinct possibility that's
an appeal
that that uh an inspector may be minded
to um
um sort of uh uphold the appeal and the
application goes ahead
um but at that stage um we have put a
lot of results and time into defending
something
that often said could not be defended
easily um there is also a risk that um
some of the negotiations that you've had
with bloor in terms of conditions and
heads of terms of section 106
are actually generous and beyond what
needs to be actually put forward
as as part of the application so there's
also risk that some of that becomes
reduced
as appeal as well so you actually end up
with a weaker application if you like
that goes through so that's one concern
i mean my main answer is that
um you know the development committee
are
duty bound by law to arrive a decision
that's based on material planning
considerations
and i think what we're saying from from
our point of view is as officers
we're we're struggling to hear those
reasons and so we wouldn't be doing our
job probably didn't bring that
to your attention so the the the idea of
referral will be to i guess to get some
further clarity around the legality and
and defendability of that position
and again i've heard that there's a talk
of course of further survey work
and i guess it's again to seek um the
possibility
of how easy that is to to weave into any
sort of further
um sort of um appeal or or
consideration that point if we bring it
back into to the committee
so there's a couple of aspects there
that would pretty soon deferral better
than probably going ahead tonight on on
a decision thank you
councillor wilkinson jeremy you wish to
drop your motion and as suggested put
another one forward for
deferral uh chairman no and i'll tell
you the reason why i'm not
um i think i don't think from what i'm
hearing from mr hodden that
um a deferment is going to relay fears
around the health the safety
aspect of that junction um i i i don't
know i i can't explain it
any other way than i already have okay i
think i trust the judgments of my
colleagues here
that if they think the firm is better
now can i ask you then to restate your
reasons for refusing before we go to a
vote then please
well i've forgotten exactly what they
are uh
exactly they've changed number of times
so first of all is over development um
the impact on the road network um the
the safety of that junction is wrong um
the safety of the children everybody
outside
uh the loss of the tree um the impact on
the wider road network
and um the um
well the last one was the um
of the local plan um i hear i hear what
yvonne said but we haven't complied with
the town and country planning act so you
can't have your cake and eat it so
and of course the the the uh youth
facilities that were
the youth facilities that council always
mentioned yes thank you
right members um we are where we are we
have had a
thorough and comprehensive um discussion
we've heard the clear advice from our
planning officers
we've had a very thorough wide
discussion
the reasons for refusal have been
restated
and uh julie seconded so i feel that we
are now duty-bound to get clarity
uh on the decision here so uh could i
ask everyone to drop
hands please
okay can i ask those members
in favor of a recorded vote to please
indicate
all right there's three the threshold
has been passed
they'll now be a recorded vote
so that this will be done on a wrong
call as previously
so those members in favor of refusal of
this application
based on the points put forward by
councillor wilkinson and seconded by
councillor shaw
so councillor eves
against against the refusal
yes in preference of a deferral
councillor william well we come to the
councillor williams
yes
councillor williams sorry i apologize i
didn't mean
um yeah i'm against a refusal at this
time thank you
councillor stanley
four councillor fd
against the refusal chair thank you
councillor merrick
against councillor gooding
against the refusal chair at the point
council
shaw
butcher
yes thank you chairman for refusal
councillor wilkinson
for the motion check how's the hawkway
thank you chairman um for the refusal
council shaw mr shaw
for the refusal myself against
councillor wilson against refusal
pending
uh deferment
i have seven against the motion
and six for the motion
can i just confirm that with a
nod of the head from sonia that's not
showing on the screen at the moment
right that motion for the refusal
is lost um
counselor uh
sorry counselor councillor williams
thank you chairman um i'd like to make a
proposal that we do furthest
um the further motion until
we can discuss the matter further with
applicants and
interested parties thank you very much
is there a second for councillor
williams yes i'll second that thank you
chairman thank you
members given the extent of the
discussion that we've already had
i i don't believe we need to have any
further discussion on the
motion for deferment
does any does any mem i've got a number
of hands up does any member need to
disc want to discuss the motion for
deferment cancer stanley your hands
still up
yes thank you chairman um
just the motion for deferral that we're
discussing yeah just the motion for
deferral uh
i don't see where that where that is
going to take us are we going to if
effective refer deferment
is going to take us into uh independent
survey of traffic
is that what we're referring to uh or
and are we still in the mines
are we still in the mines that we we
still haven't got this youth facility
it's for all the issues that the
officers
have stated councillor wilson
thank you chairman um yes i think that
um
i'd like to amend the motion if that's
possible
to include the uh independent surveys
for the traffic the pollution and also
for updating
the um the drainage survey as well
i think all those items were
with within the the the discussion
parameters
that mr hotten out outlined
councillor hawkway yeah chairman yeah i
just um
just for you know um make sure that uh
we got our p's and q's all sorted out
that um
you know i think it is an appropriate
amendment what council wilson has put
forward just to make sure that
what these um these matters are
actually taken into consideration uh
that it's part of
um what the committee wished
uh to happen as well rather than um
that it you know we we we
giving the officers um a clear
instruction in relation to uh what we
expect them to
uh to be looking at for us thank you
stanley your hand is still up
yes chairman uh i'm i'm still waiting
for katie to come back to me
on my my proposals on
the drainage and also other aspects of
what i spoke about i still haven't got
reply from you or from her thank you
um mr hotten
have you got clarity about
the issues that members have requested
you
to discuss as a result of the the
potential deferment that we'll be voting
on next
i think there's um there's almost two
threads to this
one is obviously to seek um some further
guidance around the reasons for refusal
and and the robustness and and um wisdom
of those
i guess in terms of um material reasons
in terms of planning um and the other
aspect is i hear that
obviously and this is perhaps i'm not so
clear is the quest around the
independent surveys whether we're we're
instructing
um the um applicant
to undertake further surveys which i
guess is almost another reason for
refusal
we can look at in that way or if it was
actually that we wish as a council
trying to take
further surveys uh if if it's the
the latter then um i think we still need
to go away to have some guidance because
it's not in the development committee's
gift to instruct the council
um to do so it's not something that's
within your your authority and
it's not within my authority even to
undertake that so
uh and certainly no delegated budget for
doing so so there'll be there'll be
certainly some implications for the
council's constitution to address that
as well
and so if it's if it is that latter
point then either way as part of the
determinant we'd have to look at
that as well to say whether that's
something the council could undertake
off the back of this committee thank you
so so as i'm understanding things then
if it is not within the it is not in the
committee's
uh remit to instruct for further
instruction
uh to to make that sort of instruction
but i believe
through the debate the committee
as a whole has made clear that there are
some concerns with regard to
the robustness of the traffic survey
and within the deferment that is
something that will need to be
addressed and i think that's the
appropriate way for it to be stated
denman could i just ask you politely if
i may
um the the flat roofs that are on the
houses
that we are looking at our policy
is to not put flat roofs on
roofs in other words and that was one of
my
one of my questions to katie
in the way of us policy and i never got
an
answer thank you
for the absolute satisfaction of all and
the clarity
of of where we're going katie would you
just care to quickly answer that
question
and then we vote members the discussion
has been full and robust enough
to to to allow us to do that i believe
thank you chairman apologist councillor
stanley
um there is a policy policy guidance
in relation to dormers in spd2 which
talks about
dormers being small incidental and with
pitched roofs
um obviously the dormers that we've seen
presented tonight on the plans
are not they are flat roofed there are
fl examples of flat roof dormers in the
district and
um they are sometimes allowed on new
development schemes
um they are small incidental dormers
that are proposed so
we officers haven't suggested that they
would be inappropriate
all right thank you members we are going
to vote on the deferment next
could i ask you to all drop your hands
please
chairman just on our point of order in
relation to what marcus has stated
uh in relation to um uh requesting uh
further reports and surveys um
if um he said that um if
uh officers requested the developer to
seek further reports and surveys
um what what
members have been requesting um is
uh independence survey
so um if marcus is suggesting that the
developer seeks
another assessment um what um
what what uh undertaking uh have we got
that it
will be an independent one um
[Music]
um just like marcus to um to ask well
well that that
that's that that's something i think for
outside of
of the meeting i've decided that we're
go we're going to go to the vote
the point of order is a procedural thing
um
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with the procedure that we're we're
adopting
um members first of all
we are we are voting on a motion
for deferral
which in turn will re allow for further
discussion
clarification and legal points
uh legal views to be taken on um
a way a further way forward with this
before the
application comes back to us so can i
first ask
you to raise your hand if you require a
recorded vote on deferment
the threshold has been passed there'll
now be a recorded vote based on a roll
call
if you are in favor of the deferral
please for
and uh if you're against um no so
councillor eves thank you chair four
councillor williams chairman i'm for
deferral at the moment thank you stanley
against councillor fd
ford furman chair councillor merrick
poor chairman councillor gooding
for chair thank you councillor mrs shaw
okay it's chair thank you councillor
butcher
thank you councillor wilkinson
against councillor hawkway
four chairman councillor mr shaw
against myself for
councillor wilson for deferment
just uh wait for a confirmation on my
numbers
so that motion for deferment is carried
nine
votes to four that therefore
concludes the business of the meeting
tonight
thank you very much meeting closed at
10 57 chairman good night